This episode is brought to you by Lloyd's business and commercial banking. One of the great things about finance is that it may result in you having to pay tax. And this was a constant grumble in Anglo-Saxon England, which was the most heavily taxed country in the whole of Christendom. And just when the Anglo-Saxons thought it couldn't get any worse, they got conquered by King Canute. And Canute imposed a tax rate that was effectively... 100%. Yeah, well, that was one very big change, Tom, but another tax change is upon us. And this is the advent of making tax digital for income tax. And if you're at all concerned about it, this is where Lloyd's come in, because they're here to help make that change much simpler for
本期节目由劳埃德商业银行赞助播出。金融的一大妙处在于，它可能会让你不得不纳税。这在盎格鲁-撒克逊时期的英格兰是一个永恒的抱怨，当时它是整个基督教世界中税负最重的国家。就在盎格鲁-撒克逊人以为情况不会再糟的时候，他们被克努特国王征服了。克努特征收的税率实际上达到了……100%。是的，那确实是一个巨大的变化，汤姆，但另一个税务变革也即将来临。这就是针对所得税的“税收数字化”政策。如果你对此有任何担忧，劳埃德银行可以为你提供帮助，因为他们致力于让这一转变变得更加简单，
you with a useful HMRC-recognised accounting tool that will help you stay in line with all the making tax digital requirements. And the brilliant thing about this is, is that it is free for Lloyd's business account customers. So when it is time to digitise your income tax, you can bank on Lloyd's. Search Lloyd's business accounts to find out more. Oh, history is a journey. And as we continue our journey,
他们提供了一款实用的、经英国税务海关总署（HMRC）认可的会计工具，将帮助你符合所有税收数字化的要求。最棒的是，对于劳埃德商业账户客户，这款工具是免费的。所以，当需要将你的所得税数字化时，你可以信赖劳埃德银行。搜索“劳埃德商业账户”了解更多信息。哦，历史是一段旅程。在我们继续旅程的同时，
we think of those who traveled before us. and we see and hear again the echoes of our past. A general falls to his knees in the hard snow of Valley Forge. A lonely president paces the darkened halls and ponderes his struggle to preserve the union. The men of the Alamo call out encouragement to each other. A settler pushes west. and sings a song, and the song echoes out forever, and fills the unknowing air.
我们怀念那些先于我们前行的人们。我们再次看到并听到过去的余音。一位将军在福吉谷坚硬的雪地上跪下。一位孤独的总统在黑暗的走廊里踱步，思考着他维护联邦的斗争。阿拉莫的勇士们互相呼喊着鼓励。一位定居者向西进发，唱着一首歌，歌声永远回荡，充盈在未知的空气中。
It is the American sound. It is, oh, hopeful, big-hearted, idealistic, daring, decent, and fair. That's our heritage. That's our song. We sing it still. We raise our voices to the God, who is the author of this most tender music. And may he continue to hold us close
这就是美国之声。它是充满希望的、宽宏大量的、理想主义的、大胆的、体面的、公正的。这就是我们的遗产。这就是我们的歌。我们依然在歌唱。我们向那位创作了这首最温柔乐章的上帝举起我们的声音。愿他继续将我们紧紧拥抱，
as we fill the world with our sound in unity, affection, and love. One people, under God, dedicated to the dream of freedom. God bless you and God bless America. So that absolute mush was obviously Ronald Reagan, unmistakable tones there, delivering his second inaugural address on the 21st of January,
当我们以团结、深情和爱将我们的声音传遍世界。一个在上帝之下的民族，致力于自由的梦想。上帝保佑你们，上帝保佑美国。刚才那段绝对是肉麻的陈词滥调，显然是罗纳德·里根，那标志性的语调，在1985年1月21日发表他的第二任就职演说。
1985. And Dominic, Ronald Reagan loved American history, didn't he? He loved the idea of American exceptionalism. He loved the idea of his country as a shining city on a hill. And clearly, there is no better way to kick off our new series, which is marking the 250th anniversary of the colonial tax rebellion than with that great Hollywood actor turned two times president. Yeah, you're right, Tom. Reagan absolutely believed in America's special place in the world, didn't he? I don't think any president has ever really topped it. Yeah, has drunk so deeply of the Kool-Aid than Ronald Reagan. And so what better way to kick off. I mean, I said that
多米尼克，罗纳德·里根热爱美国历史，对吧？他热爱美国例外论的理念。他热爱他那“山巅之城”的国家理念。显然，用那位伟大的好莱坞演员转型的两任总统的演讲来开启我们纪念殖民地抗税运动250周年的新系列，再合适不过了。是的，你说得对，汤姆。里根绝对相信美国在世界上拥有特殊的地位，不是吗？我不认为有哪位总统能真正超越他。是的，比罗纳德·里根喝下了更浓的“酷爱饮料”（盲目崇拜）。所以还有什么比这更好的开场方式呢。我的意思是，我说那
was much. I had to say that to reassure myself that I wasn't buying into the whole thing, because obviously we are a patriotic British podcast. We are. Yeah. So we have to keep our distance from some of the flag of liberty and all of that stuff. Yeah. All of that. So we are going to be looking at four of the founding fathers. And in due course, we are going to be looking at Benjamin Franklin and his extraordinary transatlantic career. So the sense in which he's British as well as American, we're going to be looking at the infamous duel between Aaron Burr and Alexander Hamilton. Yeah. As in the eponymous musical. And we're going to be looking at the the moral and intellectual contradictions of Thomas Jefferson. That's a kind way of putting it.
是肉麻的。我必须这么说来安慰自己，我并没有全盘接受那一套，因为显然我们是一个爱国的英国播客。我们确实是。是的。所以我们必须与那些“自由旗帜”之类的东西保持距离。是的。所有那些。所以我们将审视四位开国元勋。在适当的时候，我们将审视本杰明·富兰克林和他非凡的跨大西洋职业生涯。他既是英国人也是美国人的那种意义，我们将审视阿伦·伯尔和亚历山大·汉密尔顿之间臭名昭著的决斗。是的，就像同名音乐剧里那样。我们将审视托马斯·杰斐逊在道德和知识上的矛盾。这是一种委婉的说法。
in all kinds of ways I think the most extraordinary of the founding fathers but also perhaps the most compromised but today there can be only one candidate can't there for our opening episode and this is the most famous tax independence fighter of them all right so George Washington the man who gave his name to the capital the city where Reagan gave that speech the man who led the Continental Army through the War of Independence, and the man who, of course, became the first president of the United States. And Washington had, I mean, a really, really extraordinary life, not quite apart from his military career.
在各方面，我认为他是开国元勋中最非凡的一位，但也可能是最妥协的一位。但今天，我们的开篇剧集只能有一个候选人，对吧？那就是他们中最著名的抗税独立斗士。没错，乔治·华盛顿，那个把名字留给首都的人，里根发表那次演讲的城市，那个带领大陆军打赢独立战争的人，当然，也是成为美国第一任总统的人。华盛顿的一生，我的意思是，真的非常非常非凡，不仅仅是在他的军事生涯之外。
There's obviously his time as president. So I thought it would be fun to focus on just one particular episode. And one episode really stands out, and it's the one that Reagan alluded to in that speech. So he mentioned the moment when a general falls to his knees in the horrid snow of Valley Forge, you know, tears glistening in his eyes. Did that happen? Did it happen?
显然还有他担任总统的时期。所以我认为专注于一个特定的片段会很有趣。有一个片段确实很突出，就是里根在演讲中提到的那个。他提到了那位将军在福吉谷可怕的雪地里跪下的时刻，你知道，眼里闪烁着泪水。那件事真的发生了吗？真的发生了吗？
Well, we will be finding out. Yeah, we did a serious before about Ronald Reagan, in which Reagan tells the series of absolutely tremendous anecdotes about things that never happened. Yeah, he commented on an entire baseball match, didn't he, that never happened? Exactly. Exactly. So that sets the tone for what we'll follow. Anyway, this moment when George Washington does or does not fall to the snow in Valley Forge,
嗯，我们会找出答案的。是的，我们之前做过一个关于罗纳德·里根的系列节目，里根在其中讲述了一系列关于从未发生过的事情的极其精彩的轶事。是的，他甚至评论了一整场从未发生过的棒球比赛，不是吗？完全正确。完全正确。所以这为接下来的内容定下了基调。总之，乔治·华盛顿在福吉谷跪在雪地里的这一刻，无论是否发生过，
Many of our American listeners will immediately recognize this. I would say not one in a hundred of our British listeners will ever have heard of this moment. So we should explain just a bit of context. This moment at Valley Forge happens in the winter of 1777, 1778, and things are actually looking bleak for the American cause. So they have been fighting their tax rebellion for almost two years, but it's not going well. their capital Philadelphia, their provisional capital, has been occupied by British troops. They have been looking to the French to come in and bail them out, but so far the French have not yet officially entered the war, and it looks quite possible they might not enter at all.
我们的许多美国听众会立刻认出来。我想说，我们英国听众中一百个人里可能没一个听说过这个时刻。所以我们应该解释一点背景。福吉谷的这一刻发生在1777年到1778年的冬天，当时美国事业的前景实际上看起来很黯淡。他们已经为抗税斗争了近两年，但进展并不顺利。他们的首都费城，临时首都，已经被英军占领。他们一直指望法国人进来救场，但到目前为止，法国人还没有正式参战，而且看起来他们很有可能根本不会参战。
Although Dominic, Benjamin Franklin is on the scene to help out, so we'll be doing that in our next episode. That's right. And George Washington and his Continental Army are hold up in a place called Valley Forge, Pennsylvania. They've hold up there for the winter. they are desperately short of food and supplies and clothing. They're at the mercy of the weather. They are ravaged by disease, and they are hoping for a miracle.
虽然多米尼克，本杰明·富兰克林当时正在现场帮忙，所以我们会在下一集里讲到。没错。乔治·华盛顿和他的大陆军被困在宾夕法尼亚州一个叫福吉谷的地方。他们被困在那里过冬。他们极度缺乏食物、补给和衣物。他们受制于天气。他们饱受疾病折磨，他们正在祈求奇迹。
So this is one of the mythic moments in American sort of patriotic history. It is the episode that turns Washington into a national father figure. And before we get into the story of Valley Forge itself, we should pull back a bit and look at who Washington is and what on earth is going on with this story. So, as a recent biography of Washington, one loads of prizes, great acclaim, by Ron Chernow. And Chernow calls Washington the most elusive figure in American history, more revered than truly loved, an impossibly stiff and inflexible figure, composed of too much marble to be quite human. And one of the things that Chernow does is to show that actually he was human, he was a flesh and blood character behind the kind of marble facade. And Tom, I think you've got a tremendous anecdote, haven't you, that will illustrate this.
所以这是美国爱国历史中神话般的时刻之一。正是这一集让华盛顿成为了国家的父亲形象。在我们进入福吉谷本身的故事之前，我们应该退后一点，看看华盛顿是谁，这个故事到底是怎么回事。罗恩·切尔诺最近写的一本关于华盛顿的传记获得了许多奖项和高度赞誉。切尔诺称华盛顿为美国历史上最难以捉摸的人物，比真正被爱戴更受崇敬，一个极其僵硬和死板的人物，由太多大理石构成，以至于不太像人类。切尔诺所做的事情之一就是展示他实际上是人类，在大理石外表下是一个有血有肉的角色。汤姆，我想你有一个很棒的轶事，能说明这一点，对吧？
I do have an amusing anecdote. So it happens at the Constitutional Convention in 1787. And the guy who writes the preamble to the Constitution is a guy called Governor Morris. He sets the template for mad American names, right, from the very beginning. Suspiciously French. And he's the guy who goes on to, he's kind of involved in establishing the grid system in New York in Manhattan. Yeah. But he's a massive japster.
我确实有一个有趣的轶事。它发生在1787年的制宪会议上。写下宪法序言的那个人叫古弗尼尔·莫里斯。他从一开始就为疯狂的美国名字设定了模板，对吧？带有可疑的法国色彩。他后来参与了纽约曼哈顿网格系统的建立。是的。但他是个超级爱开玩笑的人。
So he's the funster of the constitutional. convention. And he is approached by Alexander Hamilton, as in the musical. And Hamilton says that if Morris will go up to Washington and slap him on the shoulder and say, my dear general, how happy I am to see you look so well, then Hamilton will buy him a dinner. And Morris does this. But the icy quality of Washington's stare as he greets this slap on the shoulder was so terrifying that he would not do it again for a thousand dinners. Wow. And surely he ruined the dinner. The memory of that would have ruined the dinner. It must have been a chilly occasion, I imagine. Yeah. He just let himself down. He was ashamed of himself, surely. Well, he had to go off and design grid systems to work it out of his system.
所以他是制宪会议上的开心果。亚历山大·汉密尔顿，就像音乐剧里那样，走近他。汉密尔顿说，如果莫里斯能走到华盛顿身边，拍拍他的肩膀说：“亲爱的将军，看到你气色这么好，我真高兴”，那么汉密尔顿就请他吃顿饭。莫里斯真的这么做了。但华盛顿在迎接这拍肩膀的动作时，那冰冷的眼神实在太可怕了，以至于他再也不敢为了哪怕一千顿饭再做一次。哇。而且他肯定毁了那顿饭。那段记忆肯定毁了那顿饭。我想那一定是个冷场。是的。他只是让自己失望了。他肯定为自己感到羞耻。好吧，他不得不去设计网格系统来排解这种情绪。
That's quite a good anecdote, isn't it? It's a brilliant anecdote. That's one of the best anime that's actually I think I've ever heard. Thank you. That's tremendous. Certainly the best I don't have heard about George Washington. So Washington was born in 1732. He's born into a kind of gentry family in the colony of Virginia. That's the oldest of all the British colonies in North America,
那是个相当不错的轶事，不是吗？这是一个精彩的轶事。我认为这是我听过的最好的轶事之一。谢谢。那太棒了。当然是我听过的关于乔治·华盛顿最好的轶事。所以华盛顿出生于1732年。他出生在弗吉尼亚殖民地的一个绅士家庭。那是北美所有英国殖民地中最古老的一个，
named by one friend of the show, Saul to Rally for another, Elizabeth I first. So the Washington's originally, I believe, from Tring in Hertfordshire. John Washington, Washington's great-grandfather, had started off in Tring and he had moved to Virginia. He establishes a tobacco plantation with African slave labor in the late 1650s.
由本节目的朋友索尔为另一个朋友伊丽莎白一世命名。所以华盛顿家族最初，我相信，来自赫特福德郡的特林。华盛顿的曾祖父约翰·华盛顿从特林开始，然后搬到了弗吉尼亚。他在17世纪50年代末用非洲奴隶劳工建立了一个烟草种植园。
So this is a theme that will run through this series. There's a lot of slave labor in this series. Anyway, George grows up in the 1730s and 1740s. His great ambition is to be an English country gentleman. And he does stand out. He means he's an outstanding man because he's so big. So he's six feet tall, which of course in the 1740s is very tall. It's very powerful, huge shoulders.
所以这是一个将贯穿本系列的主题。这个系列里有很多奴隶劳工。总之，乔治在18世纪30年代和40年代长大。他最大的抱负是成为一名英国乡村绅士。他确实很突出。我的意思是，他是一个杰出的人，因为他太高大了。他身高六英尺，这在18世纪40年代当然是非常高的。他非常强壮，肩膀宽阔。
Everyone talks about his massive hands. So he has to have gloves made sense. especially. He's a great horseman, and he likes riding, he likes drinking tea, and he likes reading the novels of Henry Fielding, which is nice. I'm just wondering about the cherry tree. Yeah. Because that's the other famous story that's told about him, is that he chopped down a cherry tree and then whatever said, I cannot tell a lie. Yeah, his father said, did you chop down a cherry tree? And he said, I did, I can't tell a lie. This story is itself a lie. It was invented. It was invented by a man called, of course, inevitably, an American writer called Parsons Weems.
每个人都谈论他那巨大的手。所以他必须专门定制手套。他是一位出色的骑手，他喜欢骑马，喜欢喝茶，喜欢读亨利·菲尔丁的小说，这很好。我只是在想樱桃树的事。是的。因为那是关于他的另一个著名故事，他砍倒了一棵樱桃树，然后无论谁问，都说：“我不能撒谎”。是的，他父亲说：“你砍倒了一棵樱桃树吗？”他说：“我砍了，我不能撒谎。”这个故事本身就是一个谎言。它是被发明的。它是由一个叫——当然，不可避免地——一个叫帕森·威姆斯（Parsons Weems）的美国作家发明的。
Oh, yes. And Parsons Weems will be reappears. in this story. Oh, brilliant. Barson Weems just basically goes around making stuff up. Today, he'd have a history podcast. Absolutely. About the Costa Rican Civil War. Right, anyway, so George Washington, he's this massive bloat with his huge hands.
哦，是的。帕森·威姆斯会再次出现在这个故事里。哦，太棒了。巴森·威姆斯基本上就是到处编造东西。今天，他会有一个历史播客。绝对的。关于哥斯达黎加内战的。好吧，总之，乔治·华盛顿，他就是那个有着巨大双手的大块头。
But, disappointingly, he's got a very weak voice. He's got a very thin sort of breath. He describes something a breathy voice because he had pluracy. So he speaks like Marilyn Monroe. Happy birthday, Mr. President. Exactly. To himself as he looks in the mirror. And can be just on the topic of accents? Does he have a West Country accent?
但是，令人失望的是，他的声音非常微弱。他有一种非常细的、类似呼吸的声音，因为他患有胸膜炎。所以他说话像玛丽莲·梦露。祝你生日快乐，总统先生。正是如此。当他照镜子时对自己说。多米尼克，关于口音的问题？他有西南部口音吗？
Undoubtedly. How do they talk about it in Virginia? Happy birthday. Happy birthday. Happy birthday, Mr. President. If you can basically imagine a Dorset Yokel doing Marilyn Monroe with massive hands, with Kenny Everett's hands in the 1983 General Election Rally. That's a niche reference. Didn't expect we get that in.
毫无疑问。他们在弗吉尼亚是怎么说的？祝你生日快乐。祝你生日快乐。祝你生日快乐，总统先生。如果你能想象一个多塞特郡的乡巴佬用玛丽莲·梦露的声音说话，还有那双巨大的手，就像1983年大选集会上肯尼·埃弗雷特的手一样。那是一个小众的参考。没想到我们会提到那个。
Okay. So the thing is, you said that Governor Moritz. Morris was a great funster. George Washington is a total fun. He's a massive fun sponge. He, it's often said of him, people would say they never saw him laugh. One of his officers said of him, you would seldom see a frown or smile on his countenance. His air was serious and reflecting. And part of the reason he's not keen on smiling is that he's got these terrible dental issues. So from early age, his teeth are decaying as early as 1760. So long before he's involved in the tax business.
好吧。所以问题是，你说古弗尼尔·莫里斯是个大乐子人。乔治·华盛顿是个彻底的无趣之人。他是个巨大的“乐趣海绵”。人们常说，从未见过他笑。他的一位军官说：“你很少在他的脸上看到皱眉或微笑。他的神情严肃而深思。”他不喜欢微笑的部分原因是他的牙齿问题很严重。所以从很小的时候起，他的牙齿就开始腐烂，早在1760年就开始了。所以远在他卷入税务问题之前。
One of his friends said of him, his mouth is large and generally firmly closed, but which from time to time discloses some defective teeth. Is that because of all the sugar from the plantations? Yeah, possibly. Is it a Virginia thing? I don't know. Tobacco is Virginia, really. Virginia is tobacco.
他的一位朋友说：“他的嘴很大，通常紧闭，但时不时会露出一些坏掉的牙齿。”这是因为种植园里的糖分太多了吗？是的，有可能。这是弗吉尼亚的特色吗？我不知道。烟草才是弗吉尼亚的真正特色。
Does that damage your teeth? Surely it does. Anyway, it's just got terrible teeth. Again, a theme that will run through this episode. The key to him, says Ron Chernow in his biography, is Washington's intent. self-discipline and his sense of control. So Washington is not actually as boring as you would think. He is a man of fierce passions and a hot temper, but he keeps these under sort of rigid, inflexible control. Thomas Jefferson said of him, his temper was naturally high-toned,
那会损害你的牙齿吗？肯定会。总之，他就是有一口烂牙。同样，这也是贯穿本集的一个主题。罗恩·切尔诺在传记中说，理解他的关键在于华盛顿的自我克制和控制感。所以华盛顿实际上并不像你想象的那么无聊。他是一个充满强烈激情和火爆脾气的人，但他将这些保持在一种僵硬、死板的控制之下。托马斯·杰斐逊说：“他的脾气天生高傲，
but reflection and resolution had obtained a firm and habitual ascendancy over it. John Adams, he had great self-command, but to preserve so much equanimity as he did required a great capacity. John Adams also called him a muttonhead. He did. Actually, John Adams would have said, he had a great self-command, but to reserve so much equanimity as he did required a great capacity, because that's how John Adams spoke, as we discussed in our previous American Revolution series. Anyway, the crucial moment in Washington's life comes when he's in his early 20s. Britain and France were fighting for control of North America. This is what we call the Seven Years War and what American school the French and Indian War, Washington became a commander of the Virginia
但反思和决心已经对他获得了坚定而习惯性的支配地位。”约翰·亚当斯说，他有很强的自我控制能力，但要保持他那样的平静需要巨大的能力。约翰·亚当斯还称他为“羊头”（笨蛋）。他确实这么说了。实际上，约翰·亚当斯会说：“他有很强的自我控制能力，但要保持他那样的平静需要巨大的能力”，因为这就是约翰·亚当斯的说话方式，正如我们在之前的美国革命系列中讨论的那样。总之，华盛顿生命中的关键时刻出现在他20出头的时候。英国和法国正在争夺北美的控制权。这就是我们所说的七年战争，美国学校称之为法国与印第安人战争，华盛顿成为了弗吉尼亚民兵的指挥官。
militia. And he established reputation as the preeminent colonial officer from North America, from the colonies. Everyone said, he's very brave, he's a good leader, he's very disciplined, he's great. But at the end of the war, he was denied a royal commission by his British superiors. They said, no, you know, he's not quite good enough or whatever. And he felt a deep sense of resentment. he thought basically they look down on me because I'm a mere colonial and they're from the metropolis, the imperial metropole. And they've made me grovel to them and I've got nothing out of it. And so he definitely has a sort of, you know, for him, this is personal.
他建立了作为北美殖民地最杰出殖民地军官的声誉。每个人都说，他非常勇敢，他是一位优秀的领导者，他非常有纪律，他很棒。但在战争结束时，他被英国上司拒绝了皇家委任。他们说，不，你知道，他不够好之类的。他感到一种深深的怨恨。他认为基本上他们看不起我，因为我只是个殖民地人，而他们来自大都市，帝国中心。他们让我向他们卑躬屈膝，而我什么也没得到。所以他绝对有一种，你知道，对他来说，这是个人的。
There's a chip on his shoulder. The Seven Years War has been a great triumph for Britain. But unfortunately, Tom, it creates huge problems, which is sad. Because the victory in the Seven Years War leaves Britain with this massive debt, 140 million pounds. So basically our debt has gone up 10 times to win the war. And paying interest on the debt, that alone takes up half Britain's national budget. This sounds quite familiar. Yeah, it does. Except we're not winning triumphant wars against the French. No, no. Anyway, the question is, how do you pay for this debt? Now that you've conquered all this territory
他心里有疙瘩。七年战争对英国来说是一场伟大的胜利。但不幸的是，汤姆，它造成了巨大的问题，这很可悲。因为七年战争的胜利给英国留下了巨大的债务，1.4亿英镑。所以基本上我们的债务为了赢得战争增加了10倍。光是支付债务利息就占了英国国家预算的一半。这听起来很熟悉。是的，确实。除了我们没有赢得针对法国的胜利战争。不，不。总之，问题是，你如何偿还这笔债务？既然你已经征服了所有这些领土，
in North America, how are you going to fund troops to look after it and to keep the peace, not least because there are increasing conflicts with native tribes as the settlers push West. In England, the gentry, who shoulder the tax burden, are already paying more tax than they've ever paid before. So what, 3%? Yeah, exactly. Half a percent or something. So Parliament decides it will raise revenue from the colonies themselves to pay for their own defence. I mean, that sounds entirely reasonable.
在北美，你将如何资助军队来照看它并维持和平，尤其是随着定居者向西推进，与原住民部落的冲突日益增加。在英国，承担税收负担的绅士们已经支付了比以往任何时候都多的税。所以，3%？是的，完全正确。百分之零点几之类的。所以议会决定从殖民地本身筹集收入来支付他们自己的防御费用。我的意思是，这听起来完全合理。
Quite right. And Parliament also says, well, this is the time. Basically, the British Empire, Britain's overseas possessions, have now swollen to dimensions that we never dreamed of. And the system for dealing with all this is very ramshackle and corrupt. There's all sorts of smuggling and whatnot. Basically, let's use this opportunity to sort this out and to streamline and modernize it for the age of the Enlightenment. Sensible policies for a happy America, basically. Exactly.
非常正确。议会还说，好吧，这是时候了。基本上，大英帝国，英国的海外领地，现在已经膨胀到了我们从未梦想过的规模。处理这一切的系统非常破旧且腐败。到处都是走私之类的。基本上，让我们利用这个机会解决这个问题，并为启蒙时代进行精简和现代化。基本上是为幸福的美国制定的明智政策。正是如此。
We'll have new courts. We'll have nice new customs duties. On all legal documents in America, there'll be a stamp tax as there is already in. Britain. We'll just basically streamline the whole thing. This sounds great. I mean, who could possibly object to that? It is great. Because basically, if you just follow this, you'll turn into Canada, which is brilliant, or Australia. And everyone loves those countries. However, at the time, the American colonists don't like this at all. And very, very simply, I mean, obviously this is a massive issue that we could spend hours discussing and going into all the
我们将有新的法院。我们将有很好的新关税。在美国的所有法律文件上，都会有印花税，就像英国已经有的一样。我们基本上会精简整个事情。这听起来很棒。我的意思是，谁会反对呢？这很棒。因为基本上，如果你只是遵循这个，你就会变成加拿大，这很棒，或者澳大利亚。每个人都喜欢那些国家。然而，当时，美国殖民者一点也不喜欢这样。而且非常非常简单，我的意思是，显然这是一个我们可以花几个小时讨论并深入探讨所有
nuances, but very simply. The issue is that until the 1760s, the North American colonists had basically been left alone. But what's happened now is that obviously Parliament is trying to legislate for them. Parliament says, look, it's time to sort all this out. And the more militant colonists don't like it. They don't want to be sorted out. They don't want to be interfered with. And the militants say, well, we had traditional liberties, you know, from the 17th century.
细微差别的问题，但非常简单。问题在于，直到18世纪60年代，北美殖民者基本上一直被单独对待。但现在发生的事情是，显然议会正试图为他们立法。议会说，看，是时候解决所有这些问题了。而更激进的殖民者不喜欢它。他们不想被解决。他们不想被干涉。激进分子说，好吧，我们有传统的自由，你知道，来自17世纪。
Which are English liberties. English liberties. And you're interfering with them. You don't have any right to make laws for us without our consent. And the French have been beaten. So actually, frankly, we don't really need. need you anyway, because we can probably deal with the natives ourselves. Right. So that's the thing, isn't it? That they don't actually want the British to come in and be
也就是英国人的自由。英国人的自由。而你们正在干涉它们。你们没有任何权利在没有我们同意的情况下为我们制定法律。而且法国人已经被打败了。所以实际上，坦率地说，我们真的不需要你们，因为我们可能可以自己处理原住民。对。所以这就是问题所在，不是吗？他们实际上并不希望英国人进来，对美洲原住民表现得“觉醒”。他们只是想出去抢占土地。是的，完全正确。这是一个多么伟大的爱国播客。精彩。但这确实是真的，不是吗？确实是真的。我的意思是，这就是现状。是的。而且只是指出英国人和保皇派的看法，因为别忘了，至少五分之一的美国人可能是保皇派，并保持对国王和议会的忠诚，他们说，好吧，这就是这样做的原因。不要抱怨你在议会中没有代表。英国的大多数人不在议会选举中投票。英国的许多城镇，很多都没有议员。议会运作的方式是议会是根据古老的、有机的原则选择的，这些原则已经
woke about the Native Americans. They just want to go out and grab their land. Yes, absolutely right. This is such a great patriotic podcast. Brilliant. But it's true, isn't it? It is true. I mean, that is the state of play. Yeah. And to just point out what the British and the loyalist take on, because don't forget, at least one in five Americans probably is a loyalist and stays loyal to King and Parliament, they say, well, here's the reasons for doing this. Don't go moaning about that you're not represented in Parliament. Most people in Britain don't vote in elections for Parliament. Most towns in Britain, lots of them don't have an MP. The way that Parliament works is Parliament has chosen on ancient, organic principles that have
随着时间的推移而演变。议会作为一个机构代表了我们整个英国全球大家庭，议会的法律不仅约束英国的英国臣民，也约束世界各地的英国臣民。所以议会确实为你说话，就像它为国内的每个人说话一样。现在，这并不能打动激进分子，或者说不能打动乔治·华盛顿。华盛顿在很大程度上站在这个问题的极端一侧。像七年战争后的许多土地所有者一样，他有金钱问题。
evolved over time. Parliament as a body represents our entire British global family, and Parliament's laws bind not just British subjects in Britain, but British subjects all over the world. So Parliament does speak for you as it speaks for everybody at home. Now that doesn't cut any ice with the militants or indeed with George Washington. Washington stands very much on the more extreme wing of this issue. He has money problems like a lot of landowners do after the seven years war.
烟草价格在18世纪60年代大幅下跌，所以他正在努力维持他的绅士生活方式。他背负了巨额债务，显然他讨厌支付新税的想法。他不想支付印花税。他不想支付由伦敦议会带来的玻璃、纸张或茶叶税，他从未去过那里。华盛顿也参与了，你提到了土地，非常重要。华盛顿参与了西部的土地投机，
The tobacco price had fallen considerably in the 1760s, so he's struggling to maintain his gentry lifestyle. He's run up big debts, and obviously he hates the thought of paying new taxes. He doesn't want to pay a stamp tax. He doesn't want to pay a tax on glass or paper or tea brought in by a parliament in London, where he's never been. Washington is also involved, you mentioned land, so important. Washington is involved in land speculation in the West,
当1763年，英国禁止美国在阿巴拉契亚以西定居时。所以议会说，停止。向西扩张。我们不想与原住民部落发生冲突。华盛顿崩溃了。华盛顿和他的伙伴们想参与其中。是的，当然。所以，在关系破裂的每一个点上，华盛顿都非常支持激进分子。所以他参加了1774年在费城举行的第一届大陆会议。他并没有说太多，因为当然，他担心向人们展示他的牙齿。但他非常支持鹰派。然后是1775年，在列克星敦和康科德与英军发生战斗后，
and when in 1763, Britain forbids American settlement west of the Appalachian. So Parliament says, stop it. expanding West. We don't want to get into conflict with the native tribes. Washington is gutted. Washington and his mates want to get stuck in. Yeah, of course. So at every point during the breakdown of relations, Washington is very much with the militants. So he goes to the first continental Congress in Philadelphia in 1774. And he doesn't really say much because, of course, he's worried about showing people his teeth. But he's very much on the hawkish wing. Then in 1775, after fighting is already broken out with British troops at Lexington Concord,
有第二届大陆会议。这次华盛顿穿着他的民兵制服出现。正是在这第二届大陆会议上，激进分子投票建立了一个名为“北美联合殖民地”的分裂主义准国家，它将拥有自己的大陆军来击退他们的帝国霸主。我可以问一下，这就是华盛顿穿着民兵制服出现的原因吗？当然。他怀疑这会发生。
there's a second Continental Congress. This time Washington turns up in his militia uniform. And it's at this second Continental Congress that the militants vote to set up a secessionist proto-state called the United Colonies of North America, which will have its own continental army to fight off their imperial overlords. Can I ask, is this why Washington turns up in his militia uniform? Of course. That he suspects this is going to happen.
因此，他认为需要一名指挥官。如果我穿着民兵制服出现，它将提醒每个人我是那个人。是的。战斗已经爆发，华盛顿想宣布他已经，你知道，晒黑了，休息好了，准备好对抗英国人了。所以大陆军已经建立。有人必须指挥它。有各种各样的人，但华盛顿是迄今为止最明显的。他有七年战争的军事经验。
He therefore thinks there's going to need to be a commander. And if I turn up in my militia uniform, it will serve as a nudge to everybody that I'm the guy. Yeah. Fighting has broken out and Washington wants to proclaim that he is, you know, tanned, rested and ready to take on the British. So the Continental Army has been set up. Someone's got to command it. There are various people, but Washington is by far the most obvious. He's got military experience from the seven years war.
他来自人口最多的殖民地，也就是弗吉尼亚，最古老的。关于华盛顿的另一件重要事情，这将贯穿他的职业生涯，他是一个统一者。他有点平庸。因为他有点无聊，什么也不说，没有人被他冒犯。所以马萨诸塞州的一位代表说：“他是一位完美的绅士，他明智、和蔼、有道德、谦虚且勇敢。”一位来自康涅狄格州的人。他看起来谨慎而有道德，不是那种疯疯癫癫、咆哮、咒骂的家伙，而是清醒、稳重且冷静。我的意思是，你知道，这些可能是华盛顿的墓志铭。所以现在他必须做的是，他必须将这些叛乱殖民地的民兵焊接成一支大陆军，他必须领导对英国的抵抗，可以说在这一点上是地球上最伟大的帝国力量。而且华盛顿因为他的经验而非常了解这种力量。非常了解。现在，在美国某种爱国传说中，这是一场伟大的弱者胜利。
He's from the most populous colony, which is Virginia, the oldest. And the other important thing about Washington, which will run through his career, he is a unifier. He is a bit vanilla. Because he's a bit boring and he doesn't say anything, no one's offended by him. So a delegate from Massachusetts said of him, he's a complete gentleman, his sensible, amiable, virtuous, modest and brave. A bloke from Connecticut. He seems discreet and virtuous, no hair and scarum, ranting, swearing fellow, but sober, steady and calm. I mean, you know, these could be Washington's epitaph. So now what he has to do is he has to weld the militias from these 13 rebel colonies into a continental army, and he has to lead the resistance to the British, arguably at this point the greatest imperial power on earth. And a power that Washington knows well because of his experience with them. Knows very well. Now, in American kind of patriotic legend, this is a great underdog victory.
你可以看出他们为什么会这么说。英国拥有皇家海军。英国有更多的人口。英国拥有一支训练有素的专业军队，多达5万人，英国还带来了大约3万名德国雇佣兵，即所谓的黑森人。但如果你读过这一时期杰出的美国历史学家，学术历史学家，比如一周前去世的戈登·伍德，在英国和美国的报纸上都能看到讣告。戈登·伍德指出，实际上，叛军有很多有利条件。
And you can see why they would say that. Britain has the Royal Navy. Britain has a bigger population. Britain has a trained professional army with up to 50,000 men, and Britain also brings over about 30,000 German mercenaries, the so-called Hessians. But if you read distinguished American historians, academic historians of this period, like Gordon Wood, who died a week ago, sees obituries in the papers in Britain as well as America. Gordon Wood points out, actually, the rebels have an awful lot of things going for them.
首先，他们在本土作战。英国人必须把军队送到3000英里外，你知道，在一个有巨大通信和后勤问题的时代。实际上，18世纪没有任何国家像这样在离家3000英里的地方打赢过一场战争。天哪，我想那是真的，不是吗？是的。我的意思是，以前没做过。英国人正在尝试做一些从未真正做过的事情。我想最接近的类比是征服者对美国的征服。
First of all, they're fighting on home soil. The British have to send troops 3,000 miles away, you know, in an age when there are massive communications and logistics problems. And actually no country in the 18th century has ever fought and won a war like this, 3,000 miles from home. God, I suppose that's true, isn't it? Yeah. I mean, it's not been done before. The British are trying to do something that's never really been done. I suppose the closest analogy would be the conquest of America by the conquistadors.
但它们在击败美国殖民地叛军所需的规模上什么都不是。是的，我的意思是，基本上推翻一个青铜时代国家之间有很大的区别。一个不受欢迎的政权，甚至不了解你是什么，与处理大规模叛乱之间有很大区别。我的意思是，这是一个非常重要的点。第二点，你可以派遣8万军队或任何数量，但你无法征服北美。它太大了。而且它非常适合游击战。我的意思是，它覆盖着树林、森林、湖泊和所有这些东西。
But they're nothing on the scale that's required to defeat the colonial rebels in America. Yeah, I mean, there's a big difference between basically toppling a kind of bronze age state. A widely disliked regime that doesn't even understand what you are and dealing with an insurgency on a massive scale. I mean, that's a really important point. Second point, you could send 80,000 troops or whatever, but you can't conquer North America. It's huge. And it's perfect for a guerrilla war. I mean, it's covered with woods and forests and lakes and all of these things.
即使你占领了城镇和城市，当然按欧洲标准它们非常小。那又怎样？游击队可以去乡下。所以它有一种越南战争的特质。完全有。所以我认为这是另一个问题。我认为越南绝对是正确的比较。
even if you captured the towns and cities, which of course are very small by European standards. So what? The guerrillas can just go off into the countryside. So there is a kind of Vietnam quality to it. Totally there is. So I think that's the other issue. I think Vietnam is absolutely the right comparison.
因为基本上美国人能做的是，首先，他们比英国人更关心。美国人基本上知道，我想，即使从一开始，如果他们坚持下去，他们可能会赢。英国人最终会放弃。我的意思是，在英国，有很多人同情他们。这不像英国每个人都反对这一点。不，不，有很多人同情殖民者，而且，即使你不
Because basically what the Americans can do, first of all, they care much more than the British do. The Americans basically know, I think, even from the start, that if they just keep going, they will probably win. The British will eventually give. I mean, and in Britain, there are lots of people who have sympathy with them. It's not like everyone in Britain is opposed to this. No, no, there's lots of people who sympathise with the colonists, but also, even if you don't
同情殖民者，你对印度或加勒比海，加勒比海富饶的糖岛，比对，你知道，佐治亚或佛蒙特之类的更感兴趣。我的意思是，英国没有人那么关心这些地方。所以基本上，华盛顿的工作，我的意思是，就像如果你是越共的一员之类的，他的工作是不要陷入大规模的阵地战，只要坚持下去，融入阴影，保持长期的游击战，最终英国人会妥协。他们肯定会。所以这就是接下来两年的故事。华盛顿在把这支军队建设成一支军队方面做得相当不错，尽管他经常抱怨他的手下非常放荡和无序，
sympathise with the colonists, you're much more interested in India or the Caribbean, the rich sugar islands of the Caribbean, than you are in, you know, Georgia or Vermont or something. I mean, no one in Britain cares that much about these places. So basically, Washington's job, I mean, rather like if you're a member of the Viet Cong or something, his job is don't get caught into a massive pitch battle, just keep going, melt into the shadows, keep up a long guerrilla campaign, and eventually the British will come to terms. Surely they will. And so this is the story of the next two years. Washington does a pretty good job of building this into an army, although he's often complaining that they're very licentious and disorderly his men,
因为华盛顿非常古板。他输掉的战斗比赢得的多，但按欧洲标准，这些是非常小的战斗。有点像小冲突。如果它们在欧洲打，我们会称之为小冲突。我们甚至不会认为它们是战斗。当然，按北美标准，它们是战斗。但问题是，每次他输了，他就会消失在树林里。一个很好的例子是他最大的失败之一。他在1776年被赶出纽约。
because Washington is very straight-laced. He loses far more battles than he wins, but these are very small battles by European standards. Kind of little skirmishes. If they were fought in Europe, we would call it a skirmish. We wouldn't even think of them as a battle. Of course, they're battles by North American standards. But the thing is, every time he loses, he just melts away into the woods. A good example is one of his biggest defeats. He's driven out of New York in 1776.
他从纽约向南逃往宾夕法尼亚。然后他在圣诞节跨越特拉华河，完成了这次巨大的公关政变。然后他在特伦顿和普林斯顿赢得了两场小战斗。欧洲的每个人都说，哦天哪，华盛顿，你知道，他又赢了英国人一次。华盛顿横渡特拉华河。那个。那不是很好吗？是的。
He escaped south from New York into Pennsylvania. And then he pulls off this tremendous PR coup by crossing the River Delaware at Christmas. And then he wins two little battles at Trenton and Princeton. and everybody in Europe says, oh gosh, Washington, you know, he's got one over on the British again. Washington Crossing the Delaware. That one. Wasn't that nice? Yeah.
《纹身女士莉迪亚》。汤姆，你想向人们解释那个参考吗？这是一首叫《纹身女士莉迪亚》的歌，她有各种各样的纹身，其中一个是华盛顿横渡特拉华河。就是这样。所以人们可以谷歌一下。也许你应该把整首歌作为我们历史俱乐部其他成员的额外特别奖励。你知道吗？也许吧。
Lydia the tattooed lady. Do you want to explain that reference to people, Tom? It's a song called Lydia the tattooed lady, and she has all kinds of tattoos, and one of them is Washington Crossing the Delaware. There you go. So people can Google it. Maybe you should sing the entire thing as a bonus, special bonus treat for our rest of history club members. Do you know? Maybe.
所以让我们到1777年。那年的战争情况非常复杂。一方面，美国人取得了巨大的成果。他们在萨拉托加俘虏了约翰·伯戈因将军的军队，他们俘虏了许多囚犯，这对他们来说是一场伟大的宣传政变，特别是在巴黎、马德里等欧洲首都。但对华盛顿个人来说，1777年是一场噩梦。
So let's get to 1777. It's a very mixed picture of the war that year. On the one hand, the Americans get a massive result. They captured General John Burgoyne's army at Saratoga, and they capture lots of prisoners, and that's a great propaganda coup for them, especially in the capitals of Europe, Paris, Madrid and so on. But for Washington personally, 1777, is a nightmare.
他在宾夕法尼亚农村被英国将军威廉·豪智取。他输掉了一场关键的战斗，结果是英国人在9月底能够毫无阻挡地进入叛军首都费城。而大陆会议，这是抗税的政治派别，他们已经逃离了，基本上费城只剩下妇女和儿童。华盛顿的军队在费城外，在树林里潜伏，那个秋天的士气非常非常低落。
He's outwitted by the British General William Howe in rural Pennsylvania. He loses a crucial battle, and the result of that is that the British, at the end of September, are able to march into the rebel capital of Philadelphia unopposed. And the Continental Congress, this is the kind of political wing of the tax protest, they have fled, and basically Philadelphia has been, only the women and children remain. Washington's army is outside Philadelphia, kind of lurking around in the woods, and morale that autumn is very, very low.
所以下着倾盆大雨，他们没有任何食物，纪律正在崩溃，即使是罗恩·切尔诺，他绝对是一位爱国的美国历史学家，也描述他们像在乡下掠夺，恐吓居民。所以他们基本上是在抢劫之类的，他们非常悲惨。所以让我们在几周后继续这个故事。冬天来了，华盛顿面临一个困境。他要用他的军队做什么？所以他的军队，大约有12000人，还有大约400名妇女、仆人和一般的随从。在这12000人中，有来自所有13个分裂殖民地的人，我们将在休息后更多地谈论他们。他们不能只是回家。华盛顿本人在1775年到1781年之间只回过一次家。他们需要做的是，你需要保持
So it's the pouring with rain, they haven't got any food, the discipline is breaking down, Even Ron Cherno, who's definitely a patriotic American historian, describes them as marauding through the countryside terrorizing the inhabitants. So they're basically sort of looting and stuff, and they're very miserable. So let's pick up the story a few weeks after that. Winter has come, and Washington has a dilemma. What's he going to do with his army? So his army, there's about 12,000 of them and about 400 women and servants and general hangers on. And among those 12,000 men are men from all 13 breakaway colonists, and we'll talk about them more after the break. They can't just go home. Washington himself only went home once between 1775 and 1781. What they need to do, you need to keep
军队在一起，他需要为他们找到冬营。他不想离费城太远，因为他不想把首都的农村腹地留给英国人。但他也想与在宾夕法尼亚州约克的大陆会议和在宾夕法尼亚州兰开斯特的宾夕法尼亚州立法机构保持联系。哦，所以这非常像玫瑰战争。非常像玫瑰战争。是的，我不认为那是设计好的。我认为那是演员造成的。
the army together, and he needs to find winter quarters for them. He doesn't want to retreat too far from Philadelphia, because he doesn't want to abandon the capital's kind of rural hinterland to the British. But he also wants to stay in touch with the Continental Congress, which is in York, Pennsylvania, and the Pennsylvania legislature, which is in Lancaster, Pennsylvania. Oh, so it's very Wars of the Roses. Very Wars of the Roses. Yeah, I don't think that was by design. I think that's by actor.
是的，想象那是设计好的可能有点太过了。确实。所以他选择的地方是福吉谷，距离费城西北18英里，福吉谷是一个成为美国历史上最神圣的地方之一的地方。华盛顿说它很阴沉，我认为这有点不公平。它是一个高原，是高地，被树林和原野包围。因为你在高地上，你可以看到英国人是否来了。因为有树林，你有营地的木材，有供水的溪流，
Yeah, it would be possibly pushing things too far to imagine that was by design. It would. So the place he chooses is Valley Forge, which is 18 miles northwest of Philadelphia, and Valley Forge is somewhere that becomes one of the most sacred sites in American history. Washington said it was dreary, which was a bit unfair, I think. It's a sort of plateau, it's high ground, surrounded by woods and fields. Because you're on high ground, you can see if the British are coming. Because there's woods, you've got timber for your camp, there are streams for water,
你可以基本上照看并确保英国人不会从费城出来袭击乡村。而且因为周围有农田，华盛顿希望当地人，也就是威尔士贵格会教徒，所以一次性勾选了两个非常熟悉的历史盒子，威尔士贵格会教徒会为他们提供农作物和牲畜。不幸的是，汤姆，真正持久的历史教训之一是你永远不能真正依赖威尔士贵格会教徒。所以华盛顿将在本集的后半部分学到那个教训。所以他们正在去福吉谷的路上。
and you can basically sort of keep an eye and make sure the British don't go out from Philadelphia to raid the countryside. And because there's farmland around, Washington is hopeful that the locals who are Welsh Quakers, So ticking two very familiar rest of history boxes in one go, that the Welsh Quakers will keep them supplied with crops and livestock. Unfortunately, Tom, one of the only lessons of history that really endures is that you can never truly rely on a Welsh Quaker. So Washington will learn that lesson in the second half of the episode. So they're on their way to Valley Forge.
你基本上可以留意一下，确保英国人不会从费城出来袭击乡村。由于周围有农田，华盛顿希望当地人——也就是威尔士贵格会教徒——能为他们提供农作物和牲畜，这一下子就勾选了历史中两个非常熟悉的选项。遗憾的是，汤姆，历史中唯一真正经得起考验的教训之一就是，你永远无法真正信任威尔士贵格会教徒。所以华盛顿将在本集的后半部分学到这个教训。于是他们前往福吉谷。
Washington knows, even as they're marching there, that this is going to be pretty grim. His men have run out of supplies. many of them don't have a blanket between them. About 4,000 of them don't have any boots or shoes. And Washington said later that even the march through the sleet to Valley Forge was a pretty grim ordeal. He remembered seeing men without clothes to cover their nakedness, without blankets to lay on, without shoes by which their marches might be traced by the blood from their feet,
华盛顿知道，即使在他们行军前往那里的时候，情况也相当严峻。他的士兵们补给耗尽，许多人连一条毯子都没有。大约有4000人甚至没有任何靴子或鞋子。华盛顿后来曾说，即使是穿过雨雪泥泞前往福吉谷的行军，也是一场相当惨烈的磨难。他记得看到士兵们衣不蔽体，没有毯子可以铺在身下，没有鞋子，以至于他们的行军路线可以通过脚底流出的鲜血来追踪。
marching through frost and snow without a murmur. But I think you can argue that, I mean, we've been quite down on Washington, But this is the moment when he really emerges as a national leader. Because basically, Washington says, and he has it known, has it widely known, that he will share the hardships of his men. He's not going to bunk off to Mount Vernon. He will be there with them every step of the way. And his artillery commander, Henry Knox, said to him,
他们在冰霜和积雪中行军，却毫无怨言。但我认为你可以争辩说，我的意思是，我们之前对华盛顿评价相当低，但这就是他真正展现出国家领袖风范的时刻。因为华盛顿基本上是说，并且让大家都知道，他将与他的士兵们同甘共苦。他不会躲到弗农山庄去。他会与他们并肩作战，走过每一步。他的炮兵指挥官亨利·诺克斯曾对他说：
the people of America look to you as their father, and into your hands they entrust their all, confident of every exertion on your part for their security and happiness. So basically, this is on you now. Like, you're going to, we're looking to you to get us through this. Anyway, six days before Christmas, the 19th of December, they arrive at Valley Forge. There is absolutely nothing there. No shelter.
美国人民视您为他们的父亲，将他们的一切托付给您，坚信您会为他们的安全和幸福竭尽全力。所以基本上，现在重担都在您身上了。就像是，我们指望您带领我们度过难关。总之，在圣诞节前六天，即12月19日，他们抵达了福吉谷。那里什么都没有。没有住所。
But this is the sort of challenge at which Washington excels. So he divides his men up into construction teams. He says, I want you to cut down the trees and build these cabins. American historians love these cabins. Wood cabins. Log cabins. Because they love like, they love summer camps in America, don't they? This must be the ancestor of that, winter camp.
但这正是华盛顿擅长应对的那种挑战。于是他把士兵们分成建筑小组。他说，我要你们砍伐树木，建造这些小屋。美国历史学家非常喜欢这些小屋。木屋。原木小屋。因为他们喜欢，就像他们喜欢美国的夏令营一样，不是吗？这一定是夏令营的祖先，冬令营。
Washington says, we'll have a race so you can build their cabins most quickly. And the winner gets $12. And Washington says, I'll give $100 to the team that comes up with the best way of making a waterproof roof using the least wood. So very exciting scenes. I mean, you called him a fun sponge, but that can be more fun than that. It's great fun. Winter fun, the Washington way. And actually, they do a really good job.
华盛顿说，我们要举行一场比赛，看谁能最快建好小屋。获胜者将获得12美元。华盛顿还说，我会给用最少木材造出防水屋顶的团队100美元。所以场面非常令人兴奋。我的意思是，你称他为“扫兴鬼”，但这比那更有趣。这非常有趣。华盛顿式的冬日乐趣。事实上，他们做得非常好。
They put up 2,000 log cabins within a few days. they dig trenches, they dig redoubts. Oh, we love our redoubt, don't we? We haven't had a redoubt on the show since the Battle of Poltava. Yeah, great to have the redouts back. And actually, I mean, this gives you a sign of how small North America is in terms of demography. By the time they've finished, they've built the fourth biggest city in North America with these 2,000 cabins. That's an amazing stat.
他们在几天内就搭起了2000间原木小屋。他们挖掘战壕，挖掘堡垒。哦，我们喜欢我们的堡垒，不是吗？自从波尔塔瓦战役以来，我们的节目里就没再出现过堡垒了。是的，堡垒回归真是太好了。事实上，我的意思是，这让你看出北美在人口统计学上是多么渺小。当他们完成时，他们用这2000间小屋建成了北美第四大城市。这是一个惊人的统计数据。
Anyway, I compared this momentarily to a summer camp. It is not like a summer camp. It's pouring with rain. There are dead horses everywhere. They just throw discarded wood everywhere. It's very muddy. It's very sludgy. As we will discover in the second half,
总之，我刚才把它比作夏令营。它一点也不像夏令营。外面下着倾盆大雨。到处都是死马。他们只是把废弃的木头到处乱扔。到处都是泥泞。非常泥泞。正如我们将在下半部分发现的那样，
the toilet facilities are extremely poor. Can I ask why they don't bury the horses? That baffled me. I mean, isn't it kind of basic know-how? Yeah. There's just rotting horse corpses everywhere. Yeah. A British would have buried their horses, I think.
厕所设施极其简陋。我可以问问为什么他们不把马埋了吗？这让我很困惑。我的意思是，这不是基本的常识吗？是的。到处都是腐烂的马尸。是的。我想英国人会把他们的马埋掉的。
Anyway, a lot of them haven't got any clothes And because of that, they've ripped up some tents and they're wearing them as shirts and as shoes, weirdly. One European volunteer said, afterwards, the unfortunate soldiers were in want of everything. They had neither coats, hats, shirts, nor shoes. Their feet and legs froze until they become almost black. And it was often necessary to amputate them. Now, on top of all this, they don't have enough food, because the war has destroyed the continental arm is supply chain. So to Washington's horror, the days go by, some supplies come, but they're all rotted.
总之，他们很多人没有任何衣服，正因为如此，他们撕碎了一些帐篷，把它们当作衬衫和鞋子穿，这很奇怪。一位欧洲志愿者后来写道，不幸的士兵们什么都缺。他们既没有外套、帽子、衬衫，也没有鞋子。他们的脚和腿冻得几乎发黑。而且经常需要截肢。现在，雪上加霜的是，他们没有足够的食物，因为战争摧毁了大陆军的供应链。所以令华盛顿惊恐的是，日子一天天过去，虽然有一些补给送来，但全都腐烂了。
So they live on something which they call fire cakes, which is basically they make this disgusting mixture of flour and water and they cook it on kind of heated stones. Oh my God. Sounds horrible. Yeah, they're eating flour, basically. I mean, Americans do love a big breakfast, don't they? They do.
所以他们靠一种叫“火饼”的东西生活，基本上就是把面粉和水混合成恶心的糊状物，然后在加热的石头上烤熟。哦，天哪。听起来太可怕了。是的，他们基本上是在吃面粉。我的意思是，美国人确实喜欢丰盛的早餐，不是吗？他们确实喜欢。
And before we started recording, we were discussing the quality of American food. So, you know, again, I think that will run through American history. So after a few days, they're basically like a camp of ghosts or beggars. And there's an excellent diary entry by another. splendidly named American. I've just looked at the name. He's a regimental surgeon. This can't be true.
在我们开始录音之前，我们讨论了美国食物的质量。所以，你知道，我认为这也会贯穿整个美国历史。所以几天后，他们基本上就像一群鬼魂或乞丐。另一位名字非常响亮的美国人写了一篇精彩的日记。我刚看了那个名字。他是一名团级军医。这不可能是真的。
He's called Dr. Albigents Waldo. That's just a Star Wars name, isn't it? That's just one of those Star Wars names or an NFL name. Alba Jens Waldo says, he's describing the scene, he says, poor food, hard lodging, cold weather, fatigue, nasty clothes, nasty cookery, vomit half my dime I'm going more West Country the more I do it
他叫阿尔比根斯·沃尔多医生。那简直是个《星球大战》里的名字，不是吗？那只是那种《星球大战》的名字或者NFL球员的名字。阿尔比根斯·沃尔多描述当时的场景说，食物糟糕，住宿艰苦，天气寒冷，疲惫不堪，衣服肮脏，烹饪恶心，呕吐了一半……我越说越像西南部口音了。
Smoke out of my senses The devil's in it I can endure it There comes a bowl of beef soup Full of burnt leaves and dirt Sickish enough to make a hectare spew And he on and on he goes On it goes
烟雾熏得我失去知觉，魔鬼在作祟，我快忍受不了了。端来一碗牛肉汤，里面全是烧焦的叶子和泥土。恶心到足以让一个赫克托耳呕吐。他还在继续，没完没了。
Poor food hard lodging cold weather Nasty clothes nasty cookery Tom it's like my days living in Minnesota Oh bang Bang Great banter So anyway they're all really sick They've got scabies
食物糟糕，住宿艰苦，天气寒冷，衣服肮脏，烹饪恶心，呕吐……这就像我在明尼苏达州生活的日子。哦，砰，砰，精彩的调侃。总之，他们都病得很重。他们得了疥疮。
They've got scurvy They've got typhus They've got typhoid, they've got dysentery. I mean, we emphasize dysentery, the role of dysentery in history, don't we? Yeah, and they've got loads of it. Very rarely discussed by historians, but a key key factor, the massive killer. Now, you know, I had that fact for you about this being the fourth biggest city in North America. Yeah.
他们得了坏血病，得了斑疹伤寒，得了伤寒，得了痢疾。我的意思是，我们强调过痢疾，强调过痢疾在历史中的作用，不是吗？是的，他们得了大量的痢疾。历史学家很少讨论它，但它是一个关键因素，是一个巨大的杀手。现在，你知道，我刚才告诉你关于这是北美第四大城市的那个事实。是的。
I actually have a better fact that I hope people will take away from this podcast, apart from the teeth. More Americans died at Valley Forge than at any battle of the entire war. Well, I mean, that is illustrative of the impact of dysentery on the patterns of history, isn't it? I have to say, I was really struck by that. And that's partly because the battles have basically glorified punch-ups in fields. But, you know, 2,000 people died at Valley Forge, which was the sixth of Washington's army. And more would probably have died if Washington hadn't been an enthusiastic proto-vaxxer. So it's inoculations, isn't it, at this point?
我其实有一个更好的事实，希望人们能从这期播客中记住，除了牙齿问题之外。在福吉谷死亡的美国人比整个战争中任何一场战役中死亡的人数都要多。嗯，我的意思是，这说明了痢疾对历史进程的影响，不是吗？我必须说，我对此印象非常深刻。这部分是因为那些战役基本上只是在田野里美化了的斗殴。但是，你知道，福吉谷有2000人死亡，那是华盛顿军队的六分之一。如果华盛顿不是一个热情的“原始疫苗接种者”，死亡人数可能会更多。所以这是接种，对吧，在这一点上？
Inoculations. It's not vaccination. It's inoculation. So basically what they do is they scratch your skin and they give you a very mild dose of smallpox from which you'll probably recover. Because if you get it through the skin, you're more likely to recover. And the army had been plagued by smallpox. Had Washington not organized this program of inoculation, probably more men would have died. So it's one of the more memorable scenes in John Adams, the TV series. Yeah. where they scrape a bit of pass out of one of a, someone with smallpox.
接种。这不是疫苗接种。这是人痘接种。所以基本上他们所做的是划破你的皮肤，给你接种一剂非常轻微的天花病毒，你很可能会康复。因为如果你通过皮肤感染，你更有可能康复。军队一直受到天花的困扰。如果华盛顿没有组织这个接种计划，可能会有更多人死亡。所以这是电视剧《约翰·亚当斯》中最令人难忘的场景之一。是的。他们从一个患有天花的人身上刮下一点脓液。
Franklin was very keen on this. Was he? Because he'd lost one of his sons when he was four years old to smallpox, and he hadn't inoculated him, and so he became a great proselytiser. And of course, he's the great, you know, the great scientist of America. So everyone listens to him. Yeah. I have to tell you that we gave up on John Adams as a family,
富兰克林对此非常热衷。是吗？因为他四岁的儿子死于天花，而他当时没有给他接种，所以他成了一个伟大的传教士。当然，他是美国伟大的科学家。所以每个人都听他的。是的。我必须告诉你，我们全家放弃看《约翰·亚当斯》了，
because Mrs. Sambrook said she found it interminably boring and refused to watch any more. There were similar sentiments from Mrs. Holland. And she didn't actually complain. She just fell asleep. She voted with her eyelids. Voted with her. I love it. So anyway, the inoculation campaign, this is testament to Washington's great strengths as a commander. So actually, on the battlefield, Washington is not a brilliant tactician at all. I mean, he loses most of his battles. But he is brilliant. I take my hat off to him. He is brilliant at managing his men. And this doesn't matter if the battles are just glorified skirmishes. Correct. Exactly. So he's got, he's basically, he's got his headquarters in this little
因为桑布鲁克夫人说她觉得它无聊透顶，拒绝再看下去了。霍兰夫人也有类似的情绪。她其实并没有抱怨。她只是睡着了。她用眼皮投了票。用眼皮投票。我喜欢这个。总之，接种运动，这是华盛顿作为指挥官伟大力量的证明。所以实际上，在战场上，华盛顿根本不是一个出色的战术家。我的意思是，他输掉了大部分战役。但他很出色。我向他脱帽致敬。他在管理士兵方面非常出色。如果这些战役只是美化了的冲突，这并不重要。没错。完全正确。所以他基本上把总部设在这个小小的
stone cottage at inevitably Valley Forge Creek. Hold on. How come he's got a stone cottage? Yeah, the sharing the hardships was kind of nominal for the first few days. He was in a tent for the first few days. And now he's got a stone cottage? Luxury. But, yeah. His entire reputation is a lie. We dare to tell it as it is. Yeah. It's a podcast that tells you the truth finally about top hypocrite George Washington. So here he is in his lovely stone cottage, his holiday home. with his auger. Though it's not terribly good fun because he doesn't believe in fun.
石屋里，就在福吉谷溪边。等等。他怎么会有石屋？是的，同甘共苦在最初几天只是名义上的。他最初几天住在帐篷里。现在他有了一间石屋？奢侈。但是，是的。他整个名声都是谎言。我们敢于说出真相。是的，这是一个终于告诉你关于顶级伪君子乔治·华盛顿真相的播客。所以他现在就在他可爱的石屋里，他的度假屋。带着他的钻孔机。虽然这并不怎么有趣，因为他不相信娱乐。
So dice and card games abammed and all of his aides are sleeping in the downstairs rooms and stuff. And actually, the general sense of discipline was very impressive to European visitors. So one French officer said he was struck by the air of calm dignity
所以骰子和纸牌游戏被禁止了，他所有的副官都睡在楼下的房间里等等。事实上，这种普遍的纪律感给欧洲游客留下了深刻印象。所以一位法国军官说，他被那种平静的尊严感所打动，
through which you could trace the strong feelings of the Patriot and discern the father as well as the commander of his soldiers. And this emphasis on Washington as a father figure. You know, it runs right through accounts of Valley Forge even at the time. And I think, again, that's one of his distinguishing characteristics.
从中你可以追踪到爱国者强烈的情感，并辨认出他既是士兵的父亲，也是他们的指挥官。这种将华盛顿视为父亲形象的强调。你知道，它贯穿了当时关于福吉谷的叙述。我认为，这再次成为他显著的特征之一。
Now, it's precisely because of Washington's insistence on his own dignity that Ronald Reagan's story about kneeling to prey in the snow must be false. We know it must be false. And historians have, you know, spent a lot of ink talking about, did Washington believe in God or not? Was he a Christian? because it's a slightly confusing picture. He did go to church, but he didn't go regularly. When everyone else knelt to pray, Washington would stay standing. Washington never took communion. Washington very rarely mentioned Jesus Christ.
现在，正是因为华盛顿坚持自己的尊严，罗纳德·里根关于他在雪中跪下祈祷的故事一定是假的。我们知道它一定是假的。历史学家们，你知道，花了很多笔墨讨论华盛顿是否相信上帝。他是一个基督徒吗？因为这是一个稍微令人困惑的画面。他确实去教堂，但他并不经常去。当其他人跪下祈祷时，华盛顿会站着。华盛顿从不领圣餐。华盛顿很少提到耶稣基督。
He would talk about providence, or we'd talk about the author of our being. So some historians have painted him as a deist. So, you know, God is a clockmaker. But some of Washington's mates, like James Madison, said, No, no, no, he was a very devout Anglican. And it's probably, I think the consensus actually is that in the 18th century, if you were part of the Virginia gentry, your Anglicanism was very austere and sort of restrained. I like that in Anglicanism.
他会谈论天意，或者谈论我们生命的创造者。所以一些历史学家把他描绘成自然神论者。所以，你知道，上帝是一个钟表匠。但华盛顿的一些伙伴，比如詹姆斯·麦迪逊，说，不，不，不，他是一个非常虔诚的圣公会教徒。我认为共识实际上是，在18世纪，如果你是弗吉尼亚绅士阶层的一员，你的圣公会信仰是非常朴素和克制的。我喜欢圣公会信仰中的这一点。
Yeah, you like that. Sort of small pea puritanical. Well, literally upstanding. Exactly. You want to say standing, kneeling is flummery. You don't want to do that. It's performative. And it's precisely because of that, that it's utterly implausible that Washington
是的，你喜欢。有点小写的清教徒风格。嗯，字面上是站立的。没错。你想说站着，跪下是虚伪的。你不想那样做。那是表演性的。正是因为这个原因，华盛顿跪在雪地里是完全不可信的，
would have knelt in the snow, especially where his men could have seen him. I mean, Reagan would have done that. Yeah, but Washington wouldn't. He definitely would. Oh, my lord. It would have been a lapse of the dignity. Bill Clinton would have lain down in the snow or something. Oh, God, yes.
特别是在他的士兵能看到他的地方。我的意思是，里根会那样做。是的，但华盛顿不会。他绝对不会。哦，天哪。那将是尊严的丧失。比尔·克林顿会躺在雪地里什么的。哦，天哪，是的。
Tears streaming down his cheeks. Trump would have stayed in his stained cottage. Yeah, in his gold cottage, surely. Made out of gold ingots. Well, anyway, this story, about him kneeling in the snow is absolutely fake. It was invented in 1800 after Washington's death. This is Parsons Weems again.
泪水顺着他的脸颊流下。特朗普会待在他的染色小屋里。是的，在他的黄金小屋里，肯定。用金条做的。好吧，总之，这个关于他跪在雪地里的故事绝对是假的。它是1800年在华盛顿去世后编造的。这又是帕森·威姆斯干的。
This is Parson Weems. He's an absolutely villainous man. He's a terrible man. Making up stuff randomly. But actually, do you know what? Washington should have knelt in the snow. Maybe he should have done because things are looking very bleak for him as they approach Christmas. Two days before Christmas, 23rd of December, he writes to the Continental Congress.
这是帕森·威姆斯。他是一个绝对邪恶的人。他是一个糟糕的人。随意编造东西。但实际上，你知道吗？华盛顿本应该跪在雪地里的。也许他应该这样做，因为当他们接近圣诞节时，情况对他来说看起来非常暗淡。圣诞节前两天，12月23日，他写信给大陆会议。
He says our situation here at Valley Forge is absolutely desperate. Yesterday I asked the troops to be in retinous to scour the countryside for food. He said, but they were too weak and hungry to obey. Only the efforts of my officers, he says, prevented a dangerous mutiny. I am now convinced beyond a doubt that unless some great and capital change suddenly takes place, this army must inevitably be reduced to one or other of these three things, starve, dissolve, or disperse in order to obtain subsistence. and just three or four days of bad weather would prove our destruction.
他说，我们在福吉谷的情况绝对是绝望的。昨天我要求部队去搜寻食物。他说，但他们太虚弱、太饿了，无法服从。他说，只有我军官们的努力才阻止了一场危险的兵变。我现在毫无疑问地确信，除非突然发生某种重大而根本性的变化，否则这支军队必然会陷入以下三种情况之一：饿死、解散或为了生存而分散。只要三四天的恶劣天气就会导致我们的毁灭。
So Tom, is the game up for George Washington the American cause? Are they going to abandon the rebellion, pay their taxes, obey the laws, and peacefully evolve into a warmer Canada? Well, there's only one way to find out. And spoiler, I'm afraid the answer to that is pretty disappointing. But come back after the break and find out the worst. This episode is brought to you by TikTok. Now, discovering something new. Nothing could be more thrilling than that.
那么汤姆，乔治·华盛顿和美国事业的游戏结束了吗？他们会放弃叛乱，缴纳税款，遵守法律，并和平地演变成一个更温暖的加拿大吗？好吧，只有一个办法可以找到答案。剧透一下，恐怕答案相当令人失望。但休息后回来，找出最糟糕的情况。本集由TikTok赞助。现在，发现新事物。没有什么比这更令人兴奋的了。
That's so true, Tom. So the most exciting intellectual adventure that I've been on in the last couple of years was finding out all about the siege of Shilmishl in eastern Poland, so that's during the First World War. And I went online, I read lots of books about it. But what particularly thrilled me was discovering that there's a phenomenon called Shirmishler-Tok. So people on TikTok exchanging facts about the Siege of Shamishler talking about its history, its people, and for me, that was one of the most invigorating intellectual journeys that I've ever been on.
那太对了，汤姆。所以我过去几年里经历的最令人兴奋的智力冒险是了解了第一次世界大战期间波兰东部的希尔米什尔围城战。我上网查了，读了很多关于它的书。但特别让我激动的是发现了一个叫“希尔米什尔TikTok”的现象。人们在TikTok上交流关于希尔米什尔围城战的事实，谈论它的历史、它的人民，对我来说，那是我经历过的最令人振奋的智力旅程之一。
Well, of course, studying the history of obscure First World War battles, that's the kind of thing we're all into. But there are less mainstream areas that you can discover on TikTok like history or maths or literature or cooking or music or sport or anything like that. Creators on TikTok make it easy to discover. discover something new every day. TikTok is where discovery turns into conversation. Visit TikTok.com forward slash explore more to learn more. Hello everyone and welcome back to the rest is history. It is the 23rd of December 1777 and in Valley Forge it's not looking like it's going
嗯，当然，研究晦涩的一战战役的历史，那是我们都感兴趣的事情。但TikTok上还有不太主流的领域，你可以发现，比如历史、数学、文学、烹饪、音乐、体育等等。TikTok上的创作者让发现变得容易。每天发现新事物。TikTok是发现转化为对话的地方。访问TikTok.com/exploremore了解更多。大家好，欢迎回到《历史的其余部分》。现在是1777年12月23日，在福吉谷，看起来这不会是
to be the best Christmas ever. So a very cold, miserable George Washington, even though he's, He's got his lovely stone cottage. He's still not having a fun time. He sent a desperate message to the Continental Congress, basically saying, you've got to help me out here, or the entire army is going to implode. And with it, the war effort.
有史以来最好的圣诞节。所以一个非常寒冷、悲惨的乔治·华盛顿，尽管他有他可爱的石屋，但他仍然过得不开心。他给大陆会议发了一条绝望的信息，基本上是说，你们必须在这里帮我一把，否则整支军队就会崩溃。随之而来的，是战争的努力。
Exactly so, exactly. So two days later, they have Christmas. And Washington and his age, they have a dinner, a Christmas dinner, of mutton, cabbage and crusts of bread with water to drink. Because he'd lost all his baggage in the campaign outside Philadelphia, he's only got a single spoon to eat it with.
完全正确，完全正确。所以两天后，他们过了圣诞节。华盛顿和他的副官们吃了一顿圣诞晚餐，有羊肉、卷心菜和面包皮，还有水喝。因为他在费城郊外的战役中丢失了所有的行李，他只有一个勺子可以吃东西。
So his aspirations of becoming an English country gentleman are very, very far from being realised at this moment. Well, you could say, I mean, this is the kind of training that you get at an elite English public school, don't you? It's true, actually. It's true. Kind of awful food and kind of shivering in the cold to toughen you up.
所以他成为英国乡村绅士的愿望在这一刻离实现还非常非常遥远。嗯，你可以说，我的意思是，这是你在英国精英公立学校接受的那种训练，不是吗？确实如此，真的。确实如此。那种糟糕的食物和在寒冷中颤抖来磨练你。
Yeah. If he saw it in those terms, perhaps it would have cheered him up. Maybe, exactly. Well, actually, do you know what? you say it's terribly cold. And Reagan talked about the snow and Parson Weems talked about all the snow. But it's not actually that cold.
是的。如果他从这些角度来看，也许这会让他振作起来。也许吧，完全正确。好吧，其实，你知道吗？你说天气非常冷。里根谈到了雪，帕森·威姆斯谈到了所有的雪。但实际上并没有那么冷。
So it's not a particularly cold winter. It doesn't snow that much. It's basically rain and wind that they have to worry about. Now, before the break, I mentioned that he was hoping for aid from Welsh Quakers. This was foolish.
所以这不是一个特别寒冷的冬天。雪下得并不多。基本上他们需要担心的是雨和风。现在，在休息之前，我提到他希望得到威尔士贵格会教徒的援助。这是愚蠢的。
Because basically, the locals are not that interested in helping. him. And this may surprise American listeners who have been brought up, you know, in the sort of hurrah, hurrah view of the American Revolution. Historians disagree about the exact numbers, but let's say a quarter, a third maybe even, of the colonial population, support, actually support the British in this war. The Quakerism, I think, means they're probably not desperately keen on piling into a war. But by and large, they just want to keep out. They just want to get on with their lives. And they do have food, but the British troops in Philadelphia paying them more for
因为基本上，当地人对帮助他并不感兴趣。这可能会让那些在对美国革命的“万岁，万岁”观点中长大的美国听众感到惊讶。历史学家对确切数字有分歧，但我们说，殖民地人口的四分之一，甚至三分之一，实际上支持英国。我认为贵格会教义意味着他们可能并不急于卷入战争。但总的来说，他们只是想置身事外。他们只是想继续他们的生活。他们确实有食物，但费城的英军付给他们的钱更多，
their food. So they just think, well, I'd rather sell it to the British troops in Philadelphia than I would to these blokes. Well, that's the American way, isn't it? Yeah. Capitalism is the American way. Washington is very disappointed by this. Interestingly, Washington does not think that selling to the highest bidder is the American way. So Washington at various points talks about making trading with the British punishable by death. He sends a thousand men out to basically requisition all the livestock from the local fields. So basically you'd steal it. Steal it, exactly.
所以他们只是想，好吧，我宁愿卖给费城的英军，也不愿卖给这些家伙。嗯，那是美国方式，不是吗？是的。资本主义是美国方式。华盛顿对此非常失望。有趣的是，华盛顿并不认为价高者得是美国方式。所以华盛顿在不同时期谈到要将与英国人的贸易定为死罪。他派出一千人去基本上征用当地田野里的所有牲畜。所以基本上你会偷它。偷它，完全正确。
And he says in letters, this business about selling to the highest bidder is a sign of the debasement of our national character. He says our spirit of American independence is imperiled by our own abominable lust of gain. Goodness. What would he make of Elon Musk? Yes, exactly. Very good question. And actually, the interesting thing is that Washington at this point is not quite as popular
他在信中说，这种价高者得的生意是我们民族性格堕落的标志。他说，我们的美国独立精神正受到我们自己可恶的贪婪的威胁。天哪。他会对埃隆·马斯克作何感想？是的，完全正确。很好的问题。事实上，有趣的是，华盛顿在这一点上并不像他后来那样受到他的同僚军官或国会的欢迎。所以那个冬天，当他在福吉谷时，有一场运动要罢免他的总司令职务，并引入六个月前赢得萨拉托加战役的家伙，霍拉蒂奥·盖茨将军。这场运动最终不了了之，但这提醒我们，华盛顿并不像看起来那么稳固。事实上，在1778年1月底，你知道，他一直在给国会写信。1月底，一个国会代表团访问了营地，华盛顿必须表现出最好的行为。他非常有礼貌。
with even his fellow officers or with Congress, as he would later become. So that winter, while he was a Valley Forge, there was a movement to sack him as commander-in-chief and bring in the bloke who won the Battle of Saratoga, six months earlier, General Horatio Gates. And this movement fizzled out, but it's a reminder that Washington is not as secure as he looks. And actually, at the end of January, 1778, you know, he's been writing these letters to Congress. A congressional delegation at the end of January visits the camp, Washington has to be on his very best behavior. He's very polite.
他非常尊重。他基本上恳求他们改善招募工作并理顺他们的供应链。但他真正期待的访客在几天后到来。这就是他的妻子玛莎。所以玛莎已经几个月没见到他了。她在2月初乘马车穿过冰冷的道路抵达。她和他们的一些奴隶一起来了。她到了福吉谷。
He's very respectful. And he basically begs them to improve recruitment and to sort out their supply chains. But the visitor that he's really looking forward to getting comes a few days after that. And this is his wife, Martha. So Martha hasn't seen him for months. She arrives in early February by carriage over the kind of icy roads. She's joined by some of their slaves. She gets to Valley Forge.
她对他的状况感到非常震惊。她写信给一位朋友。他很好，但因疲劳和焦虑而显得憔悴。我从未见过他像现在这样焦虑。现在，如果乔治有点难以捉摸，我必须说玛莎绝对是晦涩难懂的。所以我查了一下我的档案，2015年，我为《星期日泰晤士报》评论了一本玛莎·华盛顿的传记。我评论的最后一行写道：我不认为我读过比这更无聊的女人的传记。真的吗？总之，她到达营地，她卷起袖子，她投入工作，
She's really shocked by his. condition. She writes to a friend. He is well but much worn with fatigue and anxiety. I never knew him to be so anxious as now. Now, if George is a little bit elusive, I have to say Martha is positively opaque. So I had a look in my files and in 2015, I reviewed a biography of Martha Washington for the Sunday Times. And the final line of my review read as follows, I don't think I've ever read a biography of a more boring woman. Really? Anyway, she arrives at the camp she rolls up her sleeves she gets stuck in
她管理员工，她组织膳食，每个人都说，哦，她太棒了，你知道，我这辈子从没见过像华盛顿夫人那样从清晨忙到深夜的女人。有趣的是，他们称她为华盛顿夫人，实际上是的。现在她不是营地里唯一的女性，
she manages the staff she organises the meals everyone says oh she's brilliant you know I never in my life knew a woman so busy from early morning till late at night as was Lady Washington interesting they call a Lady Washington actually yeah very now she's not the only woman at the camp and
现代历史学家也许并不令人惊讶地非常非常热衷于强调福吉谷的普遍多样性，所以还有其他将军的妻子，这个带着“Flucker”名字的女人。我再次看到那个，心想，
modern historians perhaps unsurprisingly are very very keen to play up the general diversity of Valley Forge so there's other generals wives this woman with the ex-in. I just again just saw that and thought,
我读对了吗？它跃然纸上，不是吗？所以这是露西·弗拉克·诺克斯。这促使我问？所以我们明确一下，弗拉克不是昵称。诺克斯也不是。不。所以你写下有各位将军的妻子，有护士，还有洗衣妇。
did I read that right? It leaps off the page, isn't it? So this is Lucy Flucker Knox. So which prompts me to ask? So we clear, flucker is not a nickname. Nor is Knox. No. So you've put down that there are wives of the various generals, that there are nurses and there are laundresses.
但有妓女吗？但有妓女吗？因为，我的意思是，她们通常跟随军队，不是吗？你知道吗？我没看到任何提及，我觉得这很奇怪。我想知道这是因为美国历史学家真的不想提它，还是因为华盛顿禁止了它。华盛顿因为非常清教徒，完全有可能
But are there prostitutes? But are there prostitutes? Because, I mean, they generally follow armies, don't they? Do you know what? I haven't seen any mention, which I did find odd. And I wondered whether that was either because American historians don't really want to mention it, or because Washington forbade it. It's perfectly possible that Washington, because he is very puritanical,
他基本上试图根除它，即便如此，12000人。真的有理由相信那里没有人吗？嗯，我想他已经表现出他对疾病危险的警惕，所以这可能是可能的。是的。而且华盛顿通常非常反对女性在营地。他说，大量的女性，特别是那些怀孕或有孩子的，是每一次行动的累赘，但他无法阻止她们。现在，另一件事是种族多样性或民族多样性。所以正如我们之前所说，有来自所有13个反叛殖民地的人。有天主教徒和犹太人。有很多来自苏格兰和爱尔兰的人。有法国人。有普鲁士人。有奥地利人。波兰人、荷兰人、意大利人、西班牙人，甚至匈牙利人。现在，营地里最著名的外国人，一个你钦佩的人，
where he basically tried to stamp it out, even so, 12,000 men. Is it really plausible that there's nobody there? Well, he's shown that he's alert to the danger of disease, I suppose, so that might be possible. Yes. And Washington generally was very down on women being at the camp. He said, the multitude of women in particular, especially those who are pregnant or have children, or a clog upon every movement, but he can't stop them. Now, the other thing is the kind of the racial diversity or the ethnic diversity. So as we said before, there are men from all 13 rebel colonies. There are Catholics and Jews. There are lots of people from Scotland and Ireland. There are French. There are Prussians. There are Austrians. Poles, Dutch, Italian, Spanish, even Hungarians. Now, the most celebrated foreigner at the camp, somebody you admire
汤姆，或者你总是为他找借口，倒霉且无效的拉法耶特侯爵。他在打瞌睡吗？对，一个在法国大革命关键时刻睡着，从而完全失去主动权的人。
Tom, or you always make excuses for, the hapless and ineffective Marquis de Lafayette. Is he dazing off? Right, a man who fell asleep at the crucial moments of the French Revolution, and thereby completely lost the initiative.
所以，拉法耶特在1777年夏天以志愿者的身份抵达，当时他只有19岁。他非常理想主义。他亲自向国会陈述了参与的理由。华盛顿起初对他持怀疑态度，但在福吉谷基本上爱上了他。对拉法耶特的活力和热情印象深刻。所以他此时没有睡着。不，不，一点也没有，事实上。也许他在福吉谷耗尽了精力，这意味着当他自己国家面临危机时，他动力不足。但华盛顿
So, Malafayette had arrived in the summer of 1777 as a volunteer when he was only 19 years old. He was incredibly idealistic. He'd gone and made his case personally to Congress about being involved. Washington at first was suspicious of him, but basically fell in love with him at Valley Forge. Really impressed by Lafayette's energy and his enthusiasm. So he's not falling asleep at this point. No, no, not at all, actually. Maybe he burnt himself out at Valley Forge, and that meant he was underpowered when it came to the crisis in his own country. But Washington
收他为门徒。几乎像儿子一样，不是吗？是的。完全正确。作为代理儿子，真的。完全正确。现在，福吉谷也有一些有色人种。所以，大多数土著部落出于可以理解的原因站在英国一边，因为他们认为北美殖民者只是想偷走我们所有的土地。他们没说错。是的，他们没说错。英国人虽然可能也会夺走它们，但英国人曾做出微弱的尝试来阻止这种情况发生。但大约有50名来自奥内达部落的侦察兵。华盛顿是这些家伙的忠实粉丝。他说他们很棒。但真正引人注目的故事是非裔美国士兵的存在。如果你看网上关于这个的叙述和非常近期的历史书，在过去十年里，估计数字变得越来越大，我想可能是因为历史学家试图看到他们想看到的东西。深入了解这些细节。1778年1月，最小的殖民地，罗德岛，正在努力完成它必须派遣的配额。基本上，它是一种招募配额。华盛顿的一名军官，一个叫詹姆斯·米切尔·瓦纳姆的家伙，说，好吧，为什么不直接招募奴隶呢？把他们放进军队。对于华盛顿来说，这是一个很大的要求，因为华盛顿出生在一个拥有奴隶的家庭。华盛顿自己也拥有奴隶。他对此感到矛盾。按照奴隶主的标准，华盛顿相当人道。即便如此，他一生中购买了数十名奴隶。当1770年代与英国的危机爆发时，他拥有近100名奴隶，大约87名奴隶。
adopted him as a protégé. Kind of son almost, wasn't it? Yeah. Exactly. As a surrogate son, really. Exactly so. Now, there are also some people of colour at Valley Forge. So, most native tribes sided with the British for understandable reasons because they think the North American colonists just want to steal all our lands. And they're not wrong. Yeah, they're not wrong. And the British have, you know, although they probably would have taken them, the British have made a feeble attempt to stop this happening. But there were about 50 scouts from the Orneda tribe. And Washington was a great fan of these. fellas. He said they were brilliant. But the really striking story is the presence of African-American soldiers. And if you look at sort of online accounts of this and very recent history books, in the last decade, the estimates have kind of got bigger and bigger and bigger, I think probably because historians are trying to see what they want to see. To get into the sort of the details of this. In January 1778, the smallest colony, which was Rhode Island, was struggling to fulfil its quota that it had to send. Basically, it's kind of recruitment quota. And one of
罗恩·切尔诺，他热爱华盛顿，在他的传记中说，奴隶制编织在弗农山庄生活的方方面面，即使是对访客也是如此。尽管华盛顿有奴隶，尽管华盛顿知道南方人会对此感到震惊，但他同意了这个提议。于是罗德岛殖民地购买了117名奴隶的自由，并将他们作为士兵送往福吉谷。另外两个州随后效仿，马萨诸塞和康涅狄格。康涅狄格州的交易是，例如，如果你是奴隶主，如果你派奴隶代替你，你可以逃避兵役。但他们不是奴隶，他们不像马穆鲁克之类的。他们此时已经被解放了。
Washington's officers, who was a guy called James Mitchell Varnum, said, well, why don't you just, why don't you sign up slaves? Put them in the army. And for Washington, that's a big ask, because Washington was born into a slave-owning family. And Washington did own slaves himself. He was conflicted about it. By the standards of slave owners, Washington was pretty humane. Even so, he bought dozens of slaves during his lifetime. By the time the crisis with Britain breaks out in the 1770s, he owns for getting on 100 slaves, something like 87 slaves.
你被解放了，完全正确。你被解放并被送入军队，然后之后你将获得自由。所以到1778年8月，也就是他们失去福吉谷之后的那个时间点，军队中黑人的总数大约是755名士兵。真正有趣的是，这个领域最顶尖的历史学家是一个叫亨利·温切克的人，他说几乎没有关于任何麻烦的报道。没有关于人们抱怨的记录。没有关于种族融合引起的打架或纪律问题的记录。
Ron Cherno, who loves Washington, says in his biography, slavery was woven into every aspect of Mount Vernon life, even for visitors. Even though Washington has slaves, even though Washington knows that Southerners will be appalled by this, he agrees to this proposal. And so the colony of Rhode Island bought the freedom of 117 slaves and sent them a soldiers to Valley Forge. And two other states then followed suit, Massachusetts and Connecticut. And the deal there in Connecticut, for example, was if you're a slave owner, you could duck military service if you sent slaves in your place. But they're not slaves, they're not like the Mammalooks or something. They've been freed by this point.
温切克和切尔诺都认为，战争对华盛顿个人对待奴隶制的态度产生了巨大影响。所以正是在1778年这个时候，他告诉他家乡斯图汉姆、弗农山庄的管家，我们应该停止违背奴隶意愿出售他们。我们应该停止拆散奴隶家庭。然后在那年年底，他写信给他的管家。他顺便提到了他的奴隶。他说，我的奴隶，我每天都越来越渴望摆脱他们。
You get freed, exactly. You're freed and you're sent into the army and then afterwards you will be free. So by August 1778, so this is the point after which they've lost Valley Forge, the total of black men in the army is about 755 soldiers. And the really interesting thing, the top man on this, top historian on this is a guy called Henry Weincheck. and he says there are remarkably few reports of any trouble at all. There's no record of people complaining. There's no record of fights or interdisciplinary problems caused by racial integration.
换句话说，获得自由。我想让他们都获得自由。但他从未真正让他们都获得自由。我以为他在遗嘱里做了。嗯，不是在他有生之年，确切地说。他没有在他有生之年让他们获得自由。有一个复杂的情况，因为实际上玛莎拥有他们中的大多数。完全正确。
And both Weincheck and Chernow think that the war had a big impact on Washington personally on his attitude to slavery. So it's at this point 1778 that he tells his steward back home at Sturham, Mount Vernon, we should stop selling slaves against their will. We should stop breaking up slave families. And then at the end of the year, he's writing to his steward. He mentions his slaves in passing. And he says, my slaves, of whom I every day long more and more to get clear of.
但他确实为她去世后他们将获得自由做了一些规定。完全正确。这是一个关于华盛顿的复杂故事。我不认为有任何疑问，华盛顿认为奴隶制是错误的，他对此感到难过。正如我们将看到的杰斐逊的情况，这并不一定意味着你让你的奴隶获得自由。不，完全正确。所以回到故事，我们现在是1778年2月。他们仍然非常缺乏食物。他们仍然受到疾病的折磨。华盛顿写信给纽约州长乔治·克林顿。他说，你知道，我们在营地里非常接近饥荒。有更多关于兵变的传言。除了最积极的努力，没有什么能避免如此
In other words, set free. I'd like to set them all free. He never actually does set them all free, though. I thought he did in his will. Well, not in his lifetime, exactly. He doesn't set them free in his life time. There's a complication because actually Martha owns most of them. Exactly.
令人震惊的灾难。但一周后，是他的生日，他的47岁生日。我想你会喜欢这个细节，汤姆。他的初级军官为他组织了一场娱乐活动。这是一部由约瑟夫·艾迪生创作的关于小加图生平的英国戏剧。所以你想告诉大家小加图是谁吗？小加图是共和美德的典范，他宁愿自杀也不愿屈服于凯撒。就是这样。所以基本上他是那种华盛顿所代表的对君主制不妥协、无幽默感的反对的典范。完全正确。
But he kind of makes provisions for when she dies that they will be set free. Exactly so. It's a complicated story of Washington. I don't think there's any doubt that Washington thinks slavery is wrong and he feels bad about it. As we will see with Jefferson, that doesn't necessarily mean that you set your slaves free though. No, exactly. So back to the story, we're in February 1778. They're still very short of food. They're still suffering from disease. Washington writes to the governor of New York, George Clinton. He says, you know, we're pretty close to a famine in the camp. There are more rumours of a mutiny. Nothing but the most active efforts can avoid so
他看过这部戏好几次。他实际上可以不看剧本就大段引用其中的片段。所以他最喜欢的一些台词，低沉稳定的脾气可以审视内疚、叛乱和欺诈，在温和哲学的平静光芒中。不是凡人能命令成功，但我们会做得更多，我们会赢得它。所以所有这些关于责任、坚定、赢得成功的东西。
shocking a catastrophe. But a week later, it's his birthday, his 47th birthday. And I thought you'd like this detail, Tom. His junior officers organized an entertainment for him. And this was a British play by Joseph Addison about the life of Cato the Younger. So do you want to tell everyone who Cato the Younger is? Katie the Younger is a model of Republican virtue who prefers to commit suicide rather than submit to Caesar. There you go. So basically he's the kind of model of inflexible, humorless opposition to monarchy that Washington is all about. Exactly.
是的，这绝对是华盛顿宾果游戏。所以那是他的生日。精彩。看关于小加图的戏。第二天，一个优秀的人抵达了营地。这是一个实际上将彻底改变大陆军命运的人。
He's seen this play several times. He actually could quote bits of it at length without the text. So some of his favorite lines, Lowe's steady temper can look on guilt, rebellion and fraud in the calm lights of mild philosophy. Tis not immortals to command success. but we'll do more, we'll deserve it. So all this sort of stuff about duty, steadfastness, deserving success.
这个人叫弗里德里希·威廉·鲁道夫·格哈德·奥古斯丁·路易斯，弗雷尔·冯·斯托本·多米尼克，这位先生会是德国人吗？他是德国人。他是一个顶级的，绝对顶级的，顶尖的，普鲁士人。这个家伙冯·斯托本
Yeah, this is absolutely Washington bingo. So that's his birthday. Brilliant. Watch his play about Cato the Younger. And the next day, an excellent man arrives in the camp. And this is a man who actually is going to transform the fortunes of the Continental Army completely.
他来自普鲁士的一个军事家庭，他在七年战争中服役，他曾是一名上尉，他是腓特烈大帝的好朋友，但后来他在模糊的情况下被普鲁士军队解雇了，关于这些情况有一些线索，也许，会在接下来的几分钟里浮现。他成为了霍亨索伦-黑兴根亲王的宫廷侍从，但他觉得有点
And this is a man called Friedrich Wilhelm, Ludolf Gerhard, Augustine, Luis, Freire von Steuben Dominic, would this gentleman by any chance to be a German? He is German. He's a top, absolutely top, tip top, Prussian. And this bloke von Steuben
无聊，所以他联系了你的好朋友本杰明·富兰克林，1777年夏天，这个家伙冯·斯托本带着他的灰狗，名叫阿佐尔，他去哪儿都带着它，他的秘书，名字非常棒的皮埃尔·艾蒂安·杜蓬索，杜蓬索当时只有17岁。所以你是一个非常好看的年轻小伙子。好看的年轻人。他那长相可疑的英俊年轻副官，路易·德·庞蒂埃。好吧。所以他们降落在波士顿。他们穿着这些非常紧的红色制服，带着很多勋章。
he came from a military family in Prussia, he'd served in the Seven Years' War, he'd been a captain, he'd been a great pal of Frederick the Great, but then he'd been discharged from the Prussian army in murky circumstances, and there are some clues to those circumstances, perhaps, that will emerge in the next few moments. moments. He became the court Chamberlain for the Prince of Hoenzollon Hechingen, but he found it a bit
斯托本对美国人说，我来这里是为了你们而战。我不要报酬。我只付我的开销。那么他和英国人有什么过节呢？因为，你知道，英国和普鲁士是盟友。同一边。是的。悲哀。
boring, so he made contact with your great pal, Benjamin Franklin, and in the summer of 1777, this Blake von Steuben sailed to America with his greyhound, who was called Azor, he went with him everywhere, his secretary, the excellently named Pierre Etienne DuPonso, and DuPonso was only 17 years old. So you're very good-looking young lad. Good-looking young man. his suspiciously handsome young aide, Louis de Pontierre. Okay. So they land in Boston. They're wearing these very tight red uniforms and they've got loads of medals.
他只是为了好玩。他想和伙计们一起玩。他们紧身的制服。我认为这是吸引力的一大要素。所以他抵达福吉谷，立刻给人留下了深刻印象。他是一个长相不寻常的人。他脸颊下垂。
And Stoeven says to the Americans, I've come here to fight for you. I don't want pay. I just pay my expenses. So what's his beef with the British? Because, you know, Britain and Prussia were allies. Same side. Yeah. Sad.
他有一个巨大的红鼻子，他说的英语滑稽地糟糕。一位美国列兵后来写道，他马匹的装饰，他手枪巨大的枪套，他巨大的体型和引人注目的尚武外表，使他成为古代传说中的战神马尔斯的完美化身。
He's just there for fun. He wants to hang out and have some, you know, with the lads. And they're tight uniforms. I think it's a big element of the appeal. So he arrives at Valley Forge and he makes a great impression straight away. He's an unusual looking man. He's very jowly.
他只是为了好玩才去那里的。他想和伙计们待在一起，你知道的，享受一下时光。而且他们的制服很紧身，我认为这是吸引力的一大要素。所以他抵达了福吉谷，并立刻给人留下了深刻的印象。他长相奇特，腮帮子很大。
He's got a gigantic red nose and he speaks comically bad English. And one American private said later, the trappings of his horse, the enormous holsters of his pistols, his large size and his strikingly martial aspect made him a perfect personification of Mars, the ancient fabled god of war.
他长着一个巨大的红鼻子，英语说得滑稽地糟糕。后来有一名美国列兵说，他马匹的装饰、巨大的手枪皮套、魁梧的身材以及那引人注目的尚武气质，使他成为了战神玛尔斯——那位古老传说中的战争之神——的完美化身。
Now when Stuybin arrives, remember he's a German. he is appalled by the litter and the filth of the camp. The dead horses... I mean, we've flagged that up, haven't we? We have already, so we too are appalled by it. He says, he remembers the officer's wearing, and I quote, a sort of dressing gown made of an old blanket or woolen bed cover,
现在当施托伊本到达时，记住他是个德国人。他对营地的垃圾和污秽感到震惊。那些死马……我的意思是，我们已经提过这一点了，不是吗？我们已经提过了，所以我们也对此感到震惊。他说，他记得军官们穿着，我引用一下，“一种用旧毯子或羊毛床罩做的晨衣”，
and most of all the issue about the lack of proper toilet facilities. And he says to Washington, look, mate, and he says in his broken English, in Prussia we would not stand for this. You are literally preparing the food, feet away from the bodies of rotting horses. You have your toilets next to the kitchens and next to to people's cabins. Dig your latrines on the other side of the camp. Sort yourself out. If they are so short of food and they're reduced to eating kind of water and flour,
最重要的是缺乏合适的厕所设施的问题。他对华盛顿说，听着，伙计，他用蹩脚的英语说，在普鲁士我们可忍受不了这个。你们竟然在离腐烂马匹尸体几英尺远的地方准备食物。你们把厕所建在厨房旁边，建在人们的小屋旁边。把你们的厕所挖到营地的另一边去。整理一下你们自己。如果他们食物如此短缺，只能靠吃水和面粉度日，
why are they not eating the horses? God, I'm not an American, I don't know. God's sake, I mean, I just think I'd do a better job than Washington. Absolute shambles from Washington. Yeah. So anyway, Washington is delighted this bloke's turned up, basically because he's lost loads of officers. Some of his officers have gone home. They're sick of things. And of course, 2,000 of his men have died of disease.
为什么他们不吃马呢？天哪，我不是美国人，我不知道。看在上帝的份上，我的意思是，我只是觉得我会比华盛顿做得更好。华盛顿简直是一团糟。是的。总之，华盛顿很高兴这家伙出现了，主要是因为他损失了大量的军官。他的一些军官回家了。他们厌倦了这一切。当然，他有2000名士兵死于疾病。
So this bloke, who's a palafred at the Great, he's like a manor from heaven. And Stoibin says, I'll train your army for him. Washington gives him 120 men as guinea pigs, and Storibn basically turns them into Prussians. What he does is, he writes out the drill every day in French,
所以这家伙，这位普鲁士人，简直是天赐之物。施托伊本说，我会为你训练你的军队。华盛顿给了他120个人作为试验品，施托伊本基本上把他们变成了普鲁士人。他所做的是，每天用法语写出操练方法，
and he gets some of Washington's young officers to translate it into English for him. And do you know one of those officers who does it for him? Alexander Hamilton of musical fame Yeah Because he hangs out with Washington
然后让华盛顿的一些年轻军官为他翻译成英语。你知道其中一个为他做这件事的军官是谁吗？音乐剧里那个亚历山大·汉密尔顿。是的，因为他和华盛顿混在一起。
In the musical doesn't he? He does, yeah So, Stroibn't drill them? He teaches them to march in formation He teaches them to use a bayonets They're not, they don't have me using their bayonets property He said afterwards,
在音乐剧里是这样，对吧？是的，确实。所以，施托伊本训练他们了吗？他教他们列队行进，他教他们使用刺刀。他们之前并没有正确使用刺刀。他后来曾说，
The American soldier had no faith in it And never used it, but to roast his beefsteak And the men love him, they think he's brilliant Because they think he's very eccentric, He's funny, He's an absolutely textbook example of the hired football manager of a Premier League team
美国士兵对它没有信心，除了用来烤牛排外从不使用它。士兵们很爱他，他们认为他很棒，因为他们觉得他非常古怪，他很有趣，他简直是英超球队聘请的足球教练的教科书式案例，
who speaks only in sort of mumbled English obscenities. F this, F that. He's basically Claudio Ranieri when he was the manager of Leicester. And he's going to pull off a similarly startling feat of promotion, isn't he? Yes, exactly. So Stoybans' drills actually became the instruction manual for the US Army until like decades. still influencing American military strategy right up to the Civil War.
只会用那种嘟囔不清的英语说脏话。去他的这个，去他的那个。他基本上就是克劳迪奥·拉涅利在担任莱斯特城主教练时的样子。他将完成一项同样令人震惊的晋升壮举，不是吗？是的，完全正确。所以施托伊本的操练实际上成为了美国陆军几十年的指导手册，一直影响着美国军事战略，直到南北战争。
So Custer might have experienced it. Exactly. So the result of this is the Continental Army will leave Valley Forge, a much more modern and professional unit than they came. And afterwards, Strobun was made an American citizen. He was given a big estate in New York. And he was made a member of the American Philosophical Society, alongside loads of other founding fathers.
所以卡斯特可能也经历过。没错。所以结果就是，大陆军离开福吉谷时，是一支比他们来时更现代、更专业的部队。后来，施托伊本成为了美国公民。他在纽约获得了一大片庄园。他还成为了美国哲学学会的成员，与许多其他开国元勋并列。
He clearly had a brilliant time because he became very close to two, other handsome young men from Washington's Army in their early 20s called Benjamin Walker and William North. He adopted them. He made them his heirs, which was actually very common for gay men to do in the late 18th century. This was a way for you to establish a kind of formal relationship. When he died in 1794, he left them his estate. So it worked out well for him. It worked out well for him and for them, actually. So that's one European contribution to the insurgent effort.
他显然过得很愉快，因为他与华盛顿军队中另外两名20出头的英俊年轻人本杰明·沃克和威廉·诺斯变得非常亲密。他收养了他们。他把他们立为继承人，这在18世纪末的男同性恋者中其实非常普遍。这是一种建立某种正式关系的方式。1794年他去世时，他把庄园留给了他们。所以这对他是件好事。这对他是件好事，对他们来说也是。所以这就是欧洲对叛乱事业的一项贡献。
but obviously the Americans need more help than just this one Prussian. The war is now almost three years old, and although the British are not really anywhere in their victory, it's not clear how the Americans will ever force the British out. They have pinned their hopes all this time on French intervention. But the French, although they've sent arms, kind of surreptitiously, they haven't formally joined the war. And basically the Americans are praying that the French will one day join the war
但显然美国人需要的帮助不仅仅是这一个普鲁士人。战争现在已经进行了快三年了，虽然英国人并没有取得什么胜利，但目前还不清楚美国人将如何迫使英国人撤离。他们一直把希望寄托在法国的干预上。但法国人虽然偷偷摸摸地运送了武器，却并没有正式加入战争。基本上，美国人祈祷法国有一天能加入战争，
to challenge Britain's command of the seas. The months have passed and there's been no breakthrough, but then in the dying days of April 1778, the news reaches the insurgent camp at Valley Forge. There has been a diplomatic bombshell because at Versailles, two months earlier, your mate Benjamin Franklin, he has secured French recognition of the American Republic
以挑战英国的海上霸权。几个月过去了，没有任何突破，但在1778年4月的最后几天，消息传到了福吉谷的叛军营地。发生了一件外交重磅炸弹，因为两个月前在凡尔赛，你的朋友本杰明·富兰克林已经确保了法国对美国共和国的承认，
and a military alliance. And a month later, war was formed declared between Britain and France. And when the news reaches Valley Forge, Washington and his officers recognize this as a total game changer. Lafayette is said to have kissed Washington on the cheeks with joy, which Washington probably didn't really approve of. And a week later after they got the news, Washington is troops, they have a day of Thanksgiving,
以及军事同盟。一个月后，英国和法国正式宣战。当消息传到福吉谷时，华盛顿和他的军官们意识到这是一个彻底的转折点。据说拉法耶特高兴地亲吻了华盛顿的脸颊，华盛顿可能并不太赞成。消息传来一周后，华盛顿的部队举行了感恩节，
they fire their guns in the air, they read copies of the treatise aloud, they all shout, long live the king of France, and, I'm not a brilliant shout this, God save, the friendly powers of Europe. That didn't become an anthem. No, that didn't become an anthem. And there had loads of drinking. Everyone said that actually this time, this is the one time that Washington's
他们向空中鸣枪，大声朗读条约副本，他们都高喊，法兰西国王万岁，还有，我喊得不太好，上帝保佑欧洲的友好国家。那并没有成为国歌。不，那没有成为国歌。而且大家喝了很多酒。每个人都说，实际上这一次，这是华盛顿唯一一次，
lost his sort of imperturbable glacial exterior. He had accountants of uncommon delight. And the most shocking thing is that at the end of the day, he agreed to throw aside his dignity and to play cricket with the junior officers. Well, that is the traditional American way of celebrating, isn't it? Exactly. he was very, very good at throwing things
失去了他那种泰然自若、冷若冰霜的外表。他表现出了不同寻常的喜悦。最令人震惊的是，在一天结束时，他同意放下尊严，和初级军官们一起打板球。嗯，那是传统的美国庆祝方式，不是吗？没错。他非常非常擅长投掷东西，
because there are all these kind of mad stories of him throwing bricks over rivers and things. Right. So I think he'd be quite good at cricket. As a bowler or as a fielder? Well, the bowling, because at this point the ball was rolled along the ground rather than it wasn't kind of airborne.
因为有各种关于他把砖头扔过河流之类的疯狂故事。对。所以我认为他打板球会很不错。是作为投球手还是外野手？嗯，投球，因为当时球是沿着地面滚动的，而不是在空中飞行的。
But you know, you hit the ball, you have to throw it back in. So is this the ancestor of American enthusiasm for Tempin bowling? I think it, well, yeah, it's cool kind of part of it. Also, he had very big hands and that's very useful if you're a bowler in cricket. Of course, of course. So, French entry into the war has changed everything Because from this point onwards, the odds really are against Britain And from this point onwards, London thinks,
但你知道，你击中球后，必须把它扔回去。所以这是美国人对十瓶保龄球热情的祖先吗？我想，嗯，是的，这算是其中的一部分。而且，他的手很大，如果你是板球投球手，这非常有用。当然，当然。所以，法国参战改变了一切，因为从这一点开始，胜算确实对英国不利。从这一点开始，伦敦认为，
OK, well, the North American coloners, Southern North American coloners, what really matters is the Caribbean and the Sugar Islands. So within weeks of this, London sends a message to the new British commander in North America, Sir Henry Clinton, send a third of your army to the Caribbean. When Clinton gets this message,
好吧，北美殖民地，南北美殖民地，真正重要的是加勒比海和糖岛。所以在这之后的几周内，伦敦向北美的新任英国指挥官亨利·克林顿爵士发送了一条消息，将你三分之一的军队派往加勒比海。当克林顿收到这条消息时，
he says, well, our position in Philadelphia is now untenable. we should evacuate east to New York City. On the 16th of June, Washington at Valley Forge gets word that the British, British in Philadelphia have asked for the return of their clothes from the local laundries, which is a sign that they are moving out. It's obviously a British army would never take to the roads in unlaundered uniforms. That would be appalling. So a couple of days after this, the First American Brigades move out of Valley Forge in Hot Pursuit.
他说，好吧，我们在费城的阵地现在站不住脚了。我们应该向东撤离到纽约市。6月16日，在福吉谷的华盛顿得到消息，费城的英国人要求从当地洗衣店取回他们的衣服，这是一个他们正在撤离的信号。显然，英国军队绝不会穿着没洗过的制服上路。那太糟糕了。所以在这之后几天，第一批美国旅从福吉谷出发，紧追不舍。
By the 22nd of June, the whole continental army has crossed the Delaware into New Jersey. And on the 28th of June, a base called Monmouth Courthouse, New Jersey, Washington's men have their first military test since they've been at Valley Forge. So they have caught up with the British. The heat is overpowering. It's almost 40 degrees Celsius, so 100 degrees Fahrenheit. So hot that some soldiers actually drop dead from sunstroke. And the result of this battle, I mean, I say battle, it's basically another skirmish, is a draw, really. There's about 350 casualties on either side.
到6月22日，整个大陆军已经穿过特拉华河进入新泽西州。6月28日，在新泽西州一个叫蒙茅斯法院的地方，华盛顿的士兵们进行了自福吉谷以来的第一次军事考验。所以他们追上了英国人。天气热得让人窒息。气温几乎达到40摄氏度，也就是100华氏度。热到一些士兵甚至中暑倒地身亡。这场战斗的结果，我的意思是，我说战斗，这基本上是另一场小规模冲突，实际上是平局。双方各有约350人伤亡。
The British continued their evacuation to New York. But having lost so many battles, even a draw to Washington seems like a victory. And actually afterwards, even the British commented, they said, gosh, you know, the Americans have changed their tune. They're pretty professional. And obviously this is the result of this top Prussian, this bloat von Steuben. So where does all this leave the war? They've got out of Valley Forge. They're back on the road again. You know, things are looking up. They've got the French on their side. The war's not over, but the balance is fundamentally shifted. Because 10 days after this battle, a French fleet sails into Delaware Bay with 10 ships of the line, four frigates and 4,000 French soldiers. So from this point, the war is a global war. Britain will be on the defensive. And although American independence is not inevitable at this point in 1778, it is probably much more likely than not. Washington himself never gets the Hollywood ending that you might have thought he would have
英国人继续撤往纽约。但由于输掉了这么多场战斗，即使是对华盛顿来说，平局也感觉像是一场胜利。事实上，后来连英国人都评论说，天哪，你知道，美国人改变了调子。他们相当专业。显然这是这位顶级普鲁士人，冯·施托伊本的功劳。那么这一切让战争处于什么境地呢？他们走出了福吉谷。他们又回到了路上。你知道，情况正在好转。他们有法国人站在他们这边。战争还没有结束，但力量平衡已经发生了根本性的转变。因为在这场战斗10天后，一支法国舰队带着10艘战列舰、4艘护卫舰和4000名法国士兵驶入了特拉华湾。所以从这一点开始，战争是一场全球战争。英国将处于防御状态。虽然美国独立在1778年此时并非不可避免，但它很可能比不独立更有可能。华盛顿本人从未得到你可能认为他会喜欢的那个好莱坞式的结局，
liked, because actually Monmouth Courthouse is the last major battle in the Northern Theatre. Do you think that's why he hasn't been the hero of a kind of classic Hollywood film? And that's also maybe why the War of Independence, actually there aren't that many Hollywood films about it. There's the Patriot of Imel Gibson, but I can't actually think of any others. I mean, certainly none of those that are well known in Britain or in Europe. And part of the of that is because it ends in a very kind of desultory manner. It kind of splutters out, doesn't it? It splutters out. The British end up sort of trapping themselves at Yorktown. Washington is there, but even Ron Chernobyl's biography says this is really a victory for French siegecraft and French naval supremacy.
因为实际上蒙茅斯法院是北部战区的最后一场重大战役。你认为这就是为什么他没有成为那种经典好莱坞电影的主角吗？这也是为什么关于独立战争的好莱坞电影其实并不多的原因吗？有梅尔·吉布森的《爱国者》，但我真的想不出其他任何电影了。我的意思是，肯定没有在英国或欧洲广为人知的电影。部分原因是它以一种非常散漫的方式结束。它有点不了了之，不是吗？它不了了之。英国人最终在约克镇把自己困住了。华盛顿在那里，但即使是罗恩·切尔诺的传记也说，这实际上是法国围攻战术和法国海军霸权的胜利。
And Washington is really a supporting actor, a Yorktown. And it's a sort of slightly confusing ending. The war then, it normally goes on for another two years before the treaties at Paris is. signed. Anyway, back to Washington himself. Did Washington matter? I think the answer is undoubtedly yes, and actually this is why the story of Valley Forge is so important. Because at that moment in 1777, 1778, almost any other commander probably would have seen his army fall apart. They're hungry, they don't have supplies, the weather is terrible, you know, Congress is losing confidence in them, the men are tempted to mutiny. It's easy to imagine. The different. The different. The different colonial units turning on one another. And if the army had broken up, the Continental Army,
华盛顿在约克镇确实是一个配角。这是一个有点令人困惑的结局。战争在那之后通常还要再持续两年，直到巴黎条约签署。总之，回到华盛顿本人。华盛顿重要吗？我认为答案无疑是肯定的，实际上这就是为什么福吉谷的故事如此重要。因为在1777年、1778年的那一刻，几乎任何其他指挥官都可能眼睁睁看着他的军队分崩离析。他们挨饿，没有补给，天气恶劣，你知道，国会对他失去信心，士兵们企图哗变。很容易想象不同的殖民地部队互相攻击。如果军队解散了，大陆军，
I think it would have been pretty hard to rebuild it. I think the momentum would have been lost, even with French backing. I mean, probably the French would not have joined the war in February. And Valley Forge could have been the end of the war that could have been some sort of compromise, who knows. Now instead, of course, it becomes one of the most mythologized moments of the entire campaign. And Washington, because of his dignity, because of his leadership, because of his glacial self-control, all of which are a bit performative, but of course that's not to criticize them. It's precisely because they're so public that they're so powerful. Washington has set the tone. You know, he's played the Roman commander. He has played his hero, Cato,
我想重建它会非常困难。我认为势头会丧失，即使有法国的支持。我的意思是，可能法国人二月份就不会加入战争了。福吉谷本可能成为战争的终点，可能达成某种妥协，谁知道呢。现在相反，当然，它成为了整个战役中最被神话的时刻之一。而华盛顿，因为他的尊严，因为他的领导力，因为他冷若冰霜的自控力，所有这些都有点表演性质，但当然这并不是要批评他们。正是因为它们如此公开，所以它们才如此强大。华盛顿定下了基调。你知道，他扮演了罗马指挥官。他扮演了他的英雄加图，
and it has absolutely worked. He does the same trick again in December at 1783, so that's when the treaty was signed, and he famously walks into the Confederation Congress, and he resigns his command, and he returns to private life. Back to his plow. Back to his plow. Well, again, he's self-consciously playing a Roman. He's playing Cincinnati, isn't he? And people loved it, and George III said, oh, if he did that, he must be the greatest man in the world. You know, because people love the Romans at this point in the late 18th century. They're obsessed by this idea of honor and duty and stuff. And Republican virtue, that this is what you do in a republic, is that you don't monopolize monarchical power
而且这绝对奏效了。他在1783年12月又玩了同样的把戏，那是条约签署的时候，他著名地走进邦联国会，辞去了他的指挥权，回归私人生活。回到他的犁旁。回到他的犁旁。嗯，同样，他是有意识地扮演一个罗马人。他扮演的是辛辛纳图斯，不是吗？人们喜欢它，乔治三世说，哦，如果他那样做了，他一定是世界上最伟大的人。你知道，因为在18世纪末，人们喜欢罗马人。他们痴迷于这种荣誉、责任之类的观念。还有共和美德，这就是你在共和国里应该做的事，就是你不能垄断君主权力，
even if you're given it briefly. Exactly so. And so this will also be important for his role as the first president that he ends up laying down his power. This is why they choose him. They don't just choose him as president in 1789 because he was the victorious commander in chief.
即使你只是短暂地拥有它。没错。所以这也对他作为第一任总统的角色很重要，他最终放弃了他的权力。这就是他们选择他的原因。他们选择他担任1789年的总统不仅仅是因为他是胜利的总司令。
They choose him, I think, because he's the only one of the founding fathers who has the dignity and the self-control and the kind of paternalistic vibe that allows him to do. transcend all the factional and regional differences. The other founding fathers may be more interesting, more spiky, more distinctive in their different ways. But that means that they are, they have enemies. They have people who don't like them. Everybody likes and respects Washington.
我认为他们选择他，是因为他是开国元勋中唯一一个拥有尊严、自控力和那种家长式氛围的人，这使他能够超越所有的派系和地区差异。其他开国元勋可能更有趣、更尖锐、在不同方面更独特。但这也就意味着他们有敌人。他们有不喜欢他们的人。每个人都喜欢并尊重华盛顿。
But you said that he's got a very memorial quality, that he's like a statue hewn out of marble. And that is an enormous advantage if you have an unstable republic. And you need a kind, I'm literally heavyweight, someone who's hewned out of marble, who will provide the kind of dignity that you need in the head of state in the early years of your infant republic, but who will also serve as a kind of monument to that republic after his death. And they must all be kind of thinking of this. Yeah, I think exactly right. So we've got a bonus episode coming up for our Restis History Club members where I talk to Ken Burns, the documentary filmmaker. And he's made this massive series, a billion episodes about the American Revolution. And he says in this, Washington is the
但你说他有一种纪念碑式的品质，他就像一座大理石雕刻的雕像。如果你有一个不稳定的共和国，这是一个巨大的优势。你需要一个，我字面上说的是重量级人物，一个大理石雕刻的人，他将在你婴儿共和国的早期为国家元首提供所需的尊严，但也会在他死后作为那个共和国的纪念碑。他们一定都在考虑这一点。是的，我想完全正确。所以我们为我们的“历史其余部分”俱乐部成员准备了一个额外剧集，我将在其中与纪录片制作人肯·伯恩斯交谈。他制作了这个庞大的系列，关于美国革命的十亿集。他在其中说，华盛顿是
kind of indespent, he's the one indispensable man without which it could not have succeeded, a rare example of a great man of history who lives up to his reputation. However, just in case people are thinking they've gone mad, they've gone native, they're sucking up to the colonial. So I should stress this. Even American heroes have feet of clay, or in Washington's case, teeth of clay, Tom. Because by the time the war ends, George Washington's teeth, which end with this crucial point, are in an absolutely shocking state. By 1781, he was wearing dentures that were held together with his crude wire mesh. In 1784, so a year after the war ended, he bought nine teeth from unknown African Americans, and these teeth were then transplanted into his
那种不可或缺的人，没有他，它就不可能成功，这是一个罕见的活得名副其实的历史伟人的例子。然而，以防人们认为他们疯了，他们被同化了，他们在拍殖民者的马屁。所以我应该强调这一点。即使是美国英雄也有泥足，或者在华盛顿的情况下，是泥牙，汤姆。因为到战争结束时，乔治·华盛顿的牙齿，以这个关键点结束，处于一种绝对令人震惊的状态。到1781年，他戴着由粗糙的金属丝网固定在一起的假牙。1784年，也就是战争结束一年后，他从不知名的非裔美国人那里买了九颗牙齿，然后这些牙齿被移植到他的
gums. And by the time he became president in 1789, for all that George III said he was the greatest man in the world, he had just one working tooth left, which is why, as president, I think, he went on to save almost nothing memorable or interesting whatsoever. And Tom, that, I think, is why, since the dawn of their republic 250 years ago, Americans' terrible teeth have been the cause of so much innocent amusement all over the world, and nowhere more so, of course, of course, course than in our own beloved country in Britain. And so the ultimate lesson of this story is that if you want to have proper teeth, teeth like the British. British teeth, then you should pay your taxes. Thank you, Dominic. And we have more to come. So Benjamin Franklin is next, the great scientist and
牙龈里。到1789年他成为总统时，尽管乔治三世说他是世界上最伟大的人，但他只剩下一颗能用的牙齿了，这就是为什么作为总统，我想，他几乎没有留下任何值得纪念或有趣的事情。汤姆，我认为这就是为什么自他们共和国250年前诞生以来，美国人糟糕的牙齿在世界各地引起了如此多无辜的笑话，当然，当然，当然，在我们自己心爱的英国更是如此。所以这个故事的终极教训是，如果你想拥有合适的牙齿，像英国人那样的牙齿。英国牙齿，那么你就应该纳税。谢谢你，多米尼克。我们还有更多内容。所以接下来是本杰明·富兰克林，伟大的科学家和
diplomat in France. Then we have Alexander Hamilton and his duel with Aaron Burr and then Thomas Jefferson. We also have an amazing couple of American Revolution bonuses. So, as Dominic mentioned, the world's greatest historical documentary maker, the legendary Ken Burns. And then we will be talking to very much friend of the show Conan O'Brien for his views on the founding fathers. And on top of that, of course, there's a massive array of supplementary benefits, including our brilliant newsletter. So to get all this, the rest is history.com. you know what to do. Sign up there. And one other thing we should mention actually, so we are doing our Restless History Festival at Hampton Court this weekend. It's got tons of
外交官在法国。然后是亚历山大·汉密尔顿和他与阿伦·伯尔的决斗，然后是托马斯·杰斐逊。我们还有几个很棒的美国革命额外内容。所以，正如多米尼克提到的，世界上最伟大的历史纪录片制作人，传奇的肯·伯恩斯。然后我们将与节目的好朋友柯南·奥布莱恩谈谈他对开国元勋的看法。除此之外，当然，还有大量的补充福利，包括我们精彩的时事通讯。所以要获得所有这些，therestisthistory.com。你知道该怎么做。在那里注册。还有一件事我们应该提一下，所以我们这个周末在汉普顿宫举办我们的“历史其余部分”节。它有大量的
exciting events. The Saturday, I'm sorry to say, is sold out. That's disappointing for people who want to get tickets. But the good news is that there are still one or two tickets available, I think, for Sunday. There'll be all kinds of treats, but among them will be the appearance of Friends of the Show, Helen Castor, William Dalrymple, Adam Smith, Katia Hoyer, and very excitingly, Ian Hizlop at the end. editor of Private Eye magazine. And if you'd like to get a ticket, go to the rest is history.com. We will be back in our next episode with Benjamin Franklin. But for now, thank you, Dominic. Thank you everyone for listening. Bye-bye. Bye-bye.
激动人心的活动。很遗憾地告诉大家，周六的票已经卖光了。对于那些想买票的人来说，这很令人失望。但好消息是，我想周日还有一两张票。会有各种各样的款待，但其中将包括节目好友海伦·卡斯托、威廉·达尔林普尔、亚当·史密斯、卡蒂亚·霍耶的出现，以及非常令人兴奋的，最后是伊恩·希斯洛普，《私家侦探》杂志的编辑。如果你想买票，请访问therestisthistory.com。我们将在下一集中带着本杰明·富兰克林回来。但现在，谢谢你，多米尼克。谢谢大家的收听。再见。再见。
Hey, y'all, it's Kelly Clarkson with Wayfair. Ever order furniture online and wonder what if? Like, what if it doesn't hold up? That sofa was four days old. You should have ordered from Wayfair. With Wayfair, there's no what-if. Just style you love and quality you can trust. Visit wayfair.ca. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
嘿，大家好，我是凯莉·克拉克森，代表Wayfair。有没有在网上订购过家具，然后想“如果……会怎样？”比如，如果它不耐用怎么办？那张沙发才用了四天。你应该从Wayfair订购。在Wayfair，没有“如果”。只有你喜欢的风格和你值得信赖的质量。访问wayfair.ca。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。